Hi everybody.
Oh,
562 people.
Is this thing on?
Yeah,
I think I need to turn it up.
Turn on your hot line.
I don't know where it is.
Right.
Definitely not the top.
The ones on the very left,
the two on the left toes,
all of them sit over here.
Is that Ooh,
yeah,
that shit or that's glorious.
Oh the volume.
Your ears cleaned out yet.
No,
I did not.
I do want to and I do believe you and I'm going to do it.
I promise I'm going to try it myself.
I'm gonna order some shit online.
I just found some,
some rhino bottle and there's an elephant one in a rhino one.
I heard about that.
Yeah.
And the apparently you can do it.
It's exactly the same as the people doing the off cause it's a squeeze bottle.
Like a spray bottle you spray a cat with or something like that.
And this is like a high powered waterpik year.
Maybe.
You're right.
Yeah,
but you could buy that.
Like I told her,
I'm like,
I can I buy that.
And she's like,
no,
it's for professional use only.
And I'm thinking,
yeah,
but that means I could still buy.
You could buy it off.
It's fucking wild world out there folks.
Apparently.
Well,
let's talk about this in the podcast because I do want to bring up this a new
thing that's been going on where people are selling illegal drugs over the
internet and getting away with it.
Somehow or another.
You heard of this changing a module?
My,
no,
no.
Not even that.
Well,
we'll,
we'll get into that,
but before we get into anything,
we have commercials.
We have a very fucking flawed model,
ladies and gentlemen,
of how we handle these things.
We don't know.
We don't operate in a very professional manner and a,
I don't know if it's good or bad,
but at least you know what the fuck is up.
There's no producers behind the scenes directing Brian and I to be better at
this.
So,
um,
it's not happening.
Um,
on at.com is our sponsor.
That's our number one only real fucking serious sponsor.
Occasionally we have other sponsors,
but a on it is,
uh,
the number one thing right now.
O.
N N I t what is on it?
It is a company that w the whole mission of the company is to bring you the best
supplements,
the best fitness equipment,
the Beth,
the best choices for a healthy lifestyle.
And what Alpha brain is it is,
uh,
it's,
it's nootropics and what they are,
the vitamins that have been shown to have a positive effect on cognitive
function to have a positive effect on how your brain operates.
I take them every day.
I swear by him as do I swear by Shroom Tech Sport,
which is a fucking phenomenal,
um,
Supplement.
We got to give Jamie Kilstein son before he goes enrolls fucking stuff is
tremendous.
It's,
it's an amazing,
it's based on the quarter steps mushroom,
which has been shown to accentuate your,
your body's ability to process oxygen.
I'm not sure how it works,
but it was discovered apparently by high altitude herders who their animals,
they noticed after eating these mushrooms would have more pep to them.
And apparently it's grown off of a fucking caterpillar.
It's very complicated.
Uh,
but,
uh,
there's
you know,
like what people are able to do today,
like harvesting live organisms,
like acid off the list and,
and,
and different mushrooms and things like is it really kind of fascinating,
but the way they have to do this quarter zips mushroom is particularly difficult
but very worth it for athletes.
And it's not something that's illegal either.
It's not something where you're going to piss hot if you want to wins the
Olympics.
You know what I'm saying?
So you have to worry about it.
It's not any hooker.
They're not like steroids or anything,
but it is very effective as is this new hemp force protein that we just got.
This is the highest quality plant based protein you can buy.
And we have to get it from Canada,
unfortunately,
because we have a retarded governor man and are retarded government,
believe it or not,
even though it's legal in Vermont and I believe in two other states,
but most certainly Vermont,
they were the pioneers.
They made it illegal to grow hemp in the state of Vermont.
Well,
why is that?
Because hemp is not psychoactive.
You can't get high from it.
You will not test positive for THC.
Did you know that if you eat poppy seed bagels that you can test positive for
heroin?
Yeah.
That's how crazy this world is.
So you can't,
that does not happen with hamp.
If you eat the hemp fiber,
you do not get any THC in your system.
You've seen not going to test positive for marijuana,
but it is a really easily digestible form of protein.
And the stuff that we got is hemp hearts.
It is the highest quality stuff available.
It's not cheap.
It's expensive.
It's hard to get.
And the reason why is because our government is filled with clients.
That's it.
But it is a really effective plant based
protein and it also has maca in it and it also has raw cocoa.
It's really delicious too cause there's,
there's only one gram of sugar per serving and it is a sweetened by Stevia
instead.
And Stevia is a really,
really potent natural sweetener.
It's kind of a different flavor.
And to have the Stevia mixed with the raw cocoa in the hemp,
it's fucking delicious.
It is my all time favorite tasting protein powder.
This shit is fucking phenomenal.
I have to fight myself to keep myself from to drink in three of these a day
cause I've run through my equipment sun.
We also have a,
anyway,
we have a money back guarantee.
When you're ordering supplements,
if you ordered Alpha brain or shroom tech sport or shroom tech immune 31st 30
pills,
there's a hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't even have to send back the product.
We don't anybody to feel ripped off.
We're only selling you the best shit available.
We're only selling you shit that has been proven in some studies to have some
effect on human behavior,
human body,
the human athletic function.
Everything that we have is shit that we believe in 100% and uh,
no.
Nobody wants anybody to feel ripped off.
So we're selling you great shit.
The Best Shit that we can get our hands on.
We also have kettle bells and battle ropes available.
If you have never done those,
they're fucking tremendous real man type exercises.
Battle ropes are goddamn brutal.
You would never think throwing some ropes from would be so fucking hard,
man.
But I get out there and wail on those motherfuckers for 30 seconds and they'd
take 20 seconds off and wait on him for 30 seconds.
Holy Shit.
Is that a workout between battles?
This is,
this is,
I think all you need.
If you want to get in shape like all the,
there's a lot of people that join exercise gyms and you wind up doing stair
masters and you wind up doing,
you know,
leg extensions and all this crazy shit you do on machines.
This is all you need for fitness.
Okay?
Bodyweight squats are fucking fantastic.
That's one body weight squats,
Chin ups,
do a lot of chips.
How many chips can you really fucking do?
Go after the way down.
All the way down.
Go after it.
Okay.
Just that alone will make you ridiculously strong doing a fuck load of chin-ups.
It's a natural body weight movement and kettle bells.
And what's great about kettlebells is for there,
these cannonballs with handles.
Huh?
And they're fucking awkward as Shit and you're swinging them around and you're
forcing your body to control and bounce this giant ass cannon ball.
And when you do that,
whether you're doing it,
I'm,
sometimes I do them with two hands.
I have certain exercises that I do with two hands that are fucking brutal.
I'll take two 70 pounders and do this just ridiculous assault on your body and
you can't do it for more than 30 or 40 seconds.
But I do these 42nd reps with it.
It's what it is.
It's a,
it's cleans,
press a squat and then I swing it down,
cleans,
press,
squat,
and I do it the whole thing in a series.
And I do this,
this series,
like I try to do 20 reps nice.
And when I get to 20 reps,
it's staff.
It's fucking death.
You're swinging 140 pounds,
pressing it up,
holding in each hand.
I mean it is made me substantially stronger,
really increase my Jujitsu game,
made position stronger.
I have better balance.
I can,
I can have more.
I have more control.
I have more sovereignty over my balance.
I can move my body more the way I want to be.
Grim.
Yeah,
and that's what I ended.
The grip is tremendous too because they're heavy as shit and you're handing hell
holding onto this fat iron handle.
These kettlebells are as cheap as we can sell them.
They are the highest quality available there,
Troy kettlebells and if you fucking buy these things,
they will last until past the apocalypse.
They will last the when when the ice caps melt and this whole thing is covered
in water.
They will find these fucking kettle bells at the bottom of the ocean and try to
figure out what the hell they were all about.
Fuck your leg extensions.
Know you don't need leg extension son.
Do some body weight squats or by the way,
do some one arm pistols while holding a fucking 35 pound kettle bell.
Let me see if you could do that.
Do some one legged squats while holding a 35 pound cat about how many of those
can you do?
Bitch,
that shit is hard.
Okay.
Tremendous exercise as far as its ability to translate into athletics and
that's,
that's what I think is very important for me at least.
There's a lot of exercises that they make.
You look a little bit better,
but they don't really,
you're,
your body's not moving in a natural way.
You're isolating things and when you do that,
you can actually throw off the whole balance of how your body communicates and
now it's weight.
That's why dudes with meatball bodies meatballs on a toothpick.
We really big upper body,
a little skinny legs.
Those guys aren't athletes.
That's ridiculous.
You can't move like that.
Stupid Ladies and gentlemen.
I see end of this God damn commercial.
Oh righty.
Cue The music.
Music,
coast name and Rogan codes use.
I need a producer.
You use a codename Rogan and a,
you get 10% off.
All right.
Dirty bitches,
all supplements.
Jamie kill scenes here.
Nothing.
What happened there?
I do it a little different.
It is a non faith.
Just fucking kill it.
Yeah,
you got to give up on just trying to outdo yourself.
There's certain things in life you got to accept and you've got to accept that.
You can't make that song any better than it is.
I'm mixing it up.
Okay.
Can I say something about your sponsors real quick?
Sure.
Uh,
if the government were ever to investigate you,
your sponsors or evidence that you are trying to start an army for like when
shit goes out.
Cause like,
yeah,
like I've never heard a show like I'm used to like,
I remember like the old,
like the flashlights are people advertising.
Condoms are fucking bud light.
But it's like you need these to make you strong for when you know what happens.
But when the shit goes down and you got choke some fucking soldiers and fucking
kettlebells,
I've never heard a shit.
I'll be sponsored by fucking kettle.
Well,
um,
I want to be sponsored by Shit,
I believe in man,
which is a,
so why are we have these Alienware computers?
The only one where we,
uh,
support them because they support a MMA fighters.
They're always sponsoring fighters.
Every UFC show I go to,
I see dudes with that alien ware logo on it.
And I love that and I love that Dell has the balls to uh,
to step up and sponsor a very controversial but a very noble sport.
And so,
uh,
I appreciate that.
So we use Alienware because of that.
So I try to keep this show as,
you know,
you never going to see Brian and I advertise something that we don't believe in
it.
That it's something that sucks like this.
Like even this Alienware thing.
I would say that if you're like a regular dude and you don't game,
this is crazy.
This thing is a fucking brick look at the size of this guy damn thing.
But if you wanted to a game on it,
this is the shit.
I mean,
this thing is just like you could do,
you could play at high resolution,
like really dope high frame rate.
Oh yeah,
he played for three days.
It's already much having the best as Xbox play,
playstation three and everything in a laptop.
But if you're not a Gamer,
then that's overkill.
Oh wait,
like 80 pounds.
Hypothetically when you're dying.
The kettlebell lane,
it's really good for like hacking into the CIA.
I don't know if that goes down and tracing their steps.
So you can always be one step ahead of them that are full CPU and some hacker
skills and you need to be able to run Linux.
Okay.
What'd you,
we are also sponsored by sponsored by Linux.
We're sponsored by open source.
Listen,
I would,
I would love,
I believe in open source 100% believe in Unix and Linux
and all that stuff.
But I think that ultimately people want a little bit better of a user
experience.
We want to be able to go and buy everything and you know,
you don't want like some thing we've got to use Mike's Browser and you're like,
oh,
what does this mix browser,
you know what I mean?
And we see some of the browsers that people use and right now dorks are going
crazy.
You don't know what you're talking about.
Rogen,
you would access a wide variety of browsers that are available.
High Code,
my own,
all the heat is off me now.
That's great.
Fucking people do it.
People have gotten angry at Brian and here's one of my favorite fucking
arguments.
Oh dude was angry at Brian because we were talking about android phones.
And I always look at android phones and I look at him and like,
Woo,
that's how fucking pig screen that looks so pretty.
And then Brian was like,
yeah,
there's still clunky.
They're kind of funky
guy argued you don't even know what you're talking about.
Maybe the regular unit user interface is Clunky,
but I've hacked into my droid and I've,
you know,
used a different,
whatever the fuck they call them.
I've rooted it and use a different ls.
They,
they,
they impact the operating system changed the way it looks and they go,
see,
I have to admit something as girl I know just got the Samsung Galaxy s three and
I,
yeah.
And I started playing with,
and I,
it's not the sh the design is the shit,
like,
like big and she was lat and I just want to,
I want to have my apple on it though,
you know?
Right.
But I,
so I started using the [inaudible] system.
It was kind of cool.
There was a lot of cool little like fun features like that.
Like to take a screenshot,
you just wipe your whole hand across the screen.
I was like,
that's kind of cool,
you know,
things like that.
But then I'm like,
uh,
Africa,
what?
I think it was Facebook,
I started using Facebook.
Let me just try your Facebook APP.
And then it froze.
And I was like,
all right,
fuck this.
All right,
so let's go to the camera.
So then I'm taking the camera,
I'm trying to take a camera and it's like lagging,
like behind.
I'm just like,
fuck this shit.
You know,
they didn't under it.
That was like,
there it is right there to be a really good camera.
This is one of the things that's been,
well maybe she needed to reboot it,
but still the design of it,
I was so fucking like jealous about like,
I need it.
Like I want to
browser.
That's what,
what I'm looking at it for is like,
I like to get online from an airport or something like that and look at it like
things real quick,
you know,
like go to MMA dot.
TV or mixed martial arts or calm or something like that.
Um,
you can't see shit on an iPhone.
It's tiny going to scrawl.
Yes.
Stretch it out and just drink it up if you want to really see a picture.
Yeah.
But on these galaxies,
first of all,
the thing is the,
um,
the four g is just fucking better.
It's just better.
I,
the iPhone wants to get silly and say that a,
we're almost like four g.
If you have 18 and t pretty fucking facets.
It's pretty fast.
I don't have 18 t though.
I have a,
I have Verizon,
so it's like I'm using old shit.
I've,
I have a card in my laptop that's a four g card.
It's fucking dope,
man.
You just,
you,
it blows things up like that.
It's incredible.
It's really good.
And like,
you can watch youtube videos with no lag.
You starting them up and they play no problem.
It's really good.
But it just makes me realize how stupid the Internet is on my phone.
You know?
That's where,
that's one of the big reasons.
Got To hack into a better internet,
bro.
Yeah,
Bro,
you got to fucking learn headache.
Can you,
your kernel,
there's not say brow crowded.
Those two characters that they might,
if they're growing up,
they're growing past their current stage of nerdom.
They're experimenting with new words.
It's son,
listen bro,
Bro.
Dude,
man,
come on man.
How can this system,
bro,
how can system bro,
you can make your iPhone four g.
What's really crazy as the apple TVs,
there's a new version of apple TV that's now 10 80 p but the one before it,
the 7:20 PM you could hack into and they have like this great thing where you
just sit there and have like every single movie that's like a,
in the theaters right now it's just like imagine apple I TV.
But if it's like every single movie possible,
every single day you can sit there and watch like direct TV,
either watch,
like UFC,
like you can pretty much watch everything and it's pretty bad ass.
They had at,
at this barber shop in Atlanta when we were in Atlanta at last and I was just
like,
what is this?
And that goes,
oh,
it's apple TV.
So now if you go on Ebay or if you go on amazon.com and you look at apple TV,
like the new version,
like $99 and the old version,
it's like $300 because there's so,
but to that hack,
wait til you come back to my place.
I've been cleaning out my office and I found a fucking song on Apple Camera.
Hmm.
Oh,
back when apple made camera.
Yeah,
I remember when you buy it.
I was jealous of that camera every time I would come to your house.
I'm like,
are you gonna use that?
Because they,
cause I wanted to get one and then they went out.
They stopped selling it like the week after you,
we should use it and uh,
take uh,
well,
um,
we're to develop a website for this fucking show.
Finally,
after two years of doing it,
I figured like it should be its own website and one of the things we could do is
take photos with that shit camera and it's Shitty.
It's really cool.
I'd like to,
but it would be interesting to show people what out.
Don't open that shit.
That shit's,
you have it in the box.
Brand new.
I don't know.
A A,
maybe I did,
but not anymore.
The box is gone.
That shit was awesome.
They need to go back to make it.
I liked these cameras that are in the,
in the,
in the imax and
the camera anymore though.
Everybody wants a camera on your phone.
Yeah.
You don't want a camera anymore but like skyping and all that shit.
So Pot facetiming on your,
I use video all the time on my laptop camera that can't call anybody stupid ass.
When you're at home,
don't you ever like facetime or video chat with your family?
Like,
like hotel when you're in a hotel room like,
well there you go.
That's what
I'm saying.
That's a phone.
I'm doing that with doing that with the laptop.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
But it's not like a camera,
like a camera.
I'm saying an individual camera on its own can go suck his dick.
Oh,
right,
right.
And then the individual cameras are stupid.
I don't need you anymore.
I need,
yeah,
I don't know.
I walked by the aisle and best buy where they have like little cameras was a
little tiny camera.
Like what are you doing with this?
Yeah,
the fuck you wasting tire for do you don't have a camera on your phone yet?
All that shit.
No,
I mean the,
yeah,
but that came on the phone.
It's still not as good but we're going to force it.
We're gonna force it again.
I don't know man.
I mean like journalists and stuff.
When we were covering occupy,
like
if you look,
if,
if someone stole my phone,
I looked like a fucking crazy person because the only pictures I have in my
phone are cops beating the shit out of protestors and then,
and then you flip it and it's like,
oh there's my Hitler cat and like my fat cat and it's like my cats holding.
And then you'd turn it and it's just like a fucking bloody kid like screaming
for help and then you turn it and it's like,
aw,
pennies in a box.
Like it's fucking in my cats and police brutality is my phone.
My is half of them as Joey Dia,
smoking joints have to fill it out.
So my fuck.
So that's like the equivalent of my cat photos.
Right.
My kids and Joey Diaz smoking weed.
That's half my photos.
I got to release those to.
But I mean a lot of those photos that like kids were taking that and occupy,
we're like making it to like mainstream publications just from like iPhone like
an for sure.
Solid.
Yeah.
I mean it's amazing the video.
I mean some,
some,
some of the best like leaked video of occupied came off of phones.
Right.
And it was uploaded like instantly,
which is just so fucking bad ass.
What a weird world we live in.
Don't know,
but nobody likes it.
Have you seen this?
A new video of these cops in La beating the shit out of a homeless guy.
I mean just fucking with him and then he tries to get away and they beat the
shit out of him with clubs and kicked him.
Police brutality has gotten worse or we're just seeing it more because I think
it's gotten better.
I think it's gotten better.
I think it was way worse before they were accountable.
I think now where we're seeing it and they realize like,
do you know how much that Uc Davis cunt bag guy who sprayed pepper and those
little children's faces that a lot of you,
that piece of Shit,
you're not bad.
He must've felt after that was over the impact it must've been on is his health
right?
Almost as bad as being pepper sprayed worse.
It's all of these people responding,
coming back its worst.
Did you see the way they protest?
They protested the dean and was like the curb.
He has the silent beautiful,
amazing.
It was beautiful.
It was perfect.
Nobody fucked up.
Nobody yelled if he explained it what they did.
So what happened was,
um,
the dean who was the one who called the police and I'm on these protesters who
were a peaceful protesters are,
they weren't doing anything.
They were just like making a line.
And you know,
during that whole constituted,
it was over money.
Right?
It was over this crazy budget cuts.
Like a lot of the schools in California,
especially our,
you know,
we don't have time for school because we're not going to tax billionaires,
blah,
blah.
Which by the way,
anyone listening to the show that's like,
I'm a small business owner.
I'm the 1%,
you're not the fucking 1% unless you're a fucking billionaire or senator or
tried to tell me that I was a 1% and I was like,
come on to the,
you don't even know what that means.
You can,
you can't say one,
but that's silly.
1% it shows are really rich.
Yeah.
And they got their money by making you really poor.
Um,
and so,
so yeah,
so the dean was expecting this huge protest cause like thousands of people
showed up.
And what ended up happening when she was leaving,
it was like dusk and there were thousands of people,
but you know,
screaming and chanting or whatever.
A fucking throwing glitter,
glitter honor.
Uh,
they were silent.
It was this parking lot of like thousands of just silent people.
And she just had to walk to her car in fucking shame,
like with her head down and just beautiful.
Thousands of eyes on you and no one's saying anything.
No,
pull it up cause it's so creepy.
It's so crunchy to watch and listen to.
Yeah.
This is a better setup.
[inaudible] House.
What should I listen at?
Uc Davis.
What was their official position?
I think if you just put like silent silent protest.
Yeah,
we'll blue.
She the president of the UC Davis.
That's something,
well I want to say counselor.
You mean my description of silence doesn't convey it.
I'm 45 years old.
White guys.
I don't know what chancellor means.
Knows.
I mean,
I don't know the difference.
You said you were a chancellor and Dean Dean,
I think you're the main guy in a movie who eventually all the lesson,
you're the guy that the frat gets back at.
Yeah,
they were giving spade is your assistant or a David Spade [inaudible] character.
Let's set that.
The W at one point in time.
And that song,
that was an original movie animal house.
Oh yeah,
this is it.
Yeah.
So she steps outside with two other people and there are thousands of kids.
Thousands.
And this is all you hear is her walking and then she is surrounded by thousands
of kids on their knees.
Thousands candles.
Wouldn't it be crazy if they went
ah,
fucking charged her altogether,
right?
No.
It would be just as fucked up.
I would probably,
that's the end of the world.
That'd be a more popular movie.
That's stupid.
Yeah.
That's day the debt.
That's what starts the Zombie apocalypse.
And this is the,
they're still walking folks and they were thought while she's walking,
there are thousands of kids to the left and the right.
And I don't know how good the sound is,
but I mean there are times that you can hear a shoes.
Uh,
I mean there are times where you hear size,
like it's,
yeah,
the shoes of like the,
the photographer's chasing her.
You could hear a nose whistle.
Guess what folks,
if you can force 2000 people to be on their knees and,
and,
and be quiet like that,
they really believe what the fuck they're doing it before it.
That's real.
It's like in the Simpsons where,
uh,
Lisa breaks up with Ralph and they go,
if you rewind,
why did,
you can actually hear where it was heartbreaks.
And they do check that some that a sound that's some right versus wrong shit
right there and pretty clear forums.
So here's a question I have for you.
I think you'd be a good person to ask about police brutality is,
there's part of me,
the thing,
so like,
people really loved the idea of tasers and you know,
even weapons,
they use that at protests like rubber bullets and stuff like that.
And even though now it's come out that,
you know,
many people have died many times the people who have been tasered have been the
elderly,
mentally handicapped people who really did not innocent people,
children,
people who did not,
uh,
necessarily need to be born really a threat.
Right?
I mean,
there was literally a story recently,
we talked about it on the show,
but I'm forgetting the details,
but a kid
was just like getting suspended or whatever.
And a cop was standing there and like,
like she tried to run her sounding like,
fuck Taser like children.
It was a young kid.
Right,
right.
So,
so my question is,
and I think I have my,
my answer on what I think is that,
um,
part of me thinks that like,
and I'm not like going after all the police,
like,
I don't want to fucking tweets about like your dad being a good cop.
I'm just saying like,
the people who have like Tasers,
Paula did,
people who have tasered children,
but let's start there.
Um,
part of me is just like,
what happened to,
I get up there like an actual threat,
then the Taser is better than like shooting a guy to death.
Right?
Um,
but if you're not a threat,
if you're unarmed,
if you're just being like difficult,
like what happened to like cops having to fucking subdued these people?
Like why are all these like MMA guys doing like fucking Jujitsu seminars for law
enforcement?
If people have just started fucking tape,
like,
that wasn't the point of the Taser.
The Taser was supposed to be,
uh,
before deadly threat.
So they're not proposing enough of a threat where you have to use,
I'm sorry,
deadly force because I remember like,
do you remember when that dude like ran under the baseball field and he got
tased?
Uh,
and it was this really popular youtube clip cause they were like,
ah,
dudes getting tased.
And I remember even liberals that follow me on Twitter when I was like,
so this is fucked up.
Um,
would like that's what he gets bro.
That's what he gets for running on to a baseball field.
I'm like,
he gets a fucking electrocuted.
Like what happened to the days where the cops had to get off their fucking ass.
Chase someone be in good shape and just,
I agree.
I disagree with you there.
Okay.
I think Taser the fuck on the idiot that runs in the field because he's a
retard.
Okay.
And we need to show everybody that it really sucks when you run onto a field
because we've got a shitty stupid cavity,
a copycat society where if one asshole gets away with charging,
you know a a baseball player and gets a high five out of the baseball player
before he gets tackled to the ground.
By the way,
raise the officers that are tackling to the ground.
When you get into a physical altercation with somebody,
you risk really getting hurt and you,
and you're a guy who's just look at this.
This guy's running around.
He's a fucking idiot.
He's ruining the game toys or this asshole.
We can all agree.
Okay,
once it's down,
they shouldn't get tasered him.
This is what the problem is.
Unless they tasered him to drop it and look like he dropped himself,
that is one of those ones that shoot out.
Let me say it came back it up again.
Let me say it because it looked to me for a second there.
Like he lied down and then they tasered him when they came.
I know it's when the ones that shoot out,
there's little spikes with the cables.
Oh,
okay.
My favorite.
Okay.
Zap some in the back right there and that's when he goes down.
Well,
yeah.
Fuck that guy.
That guy's an idiot.
Guys running around the field.
He's a retard.
These poor guys with families and lives and needs and bodies,
what they should have to risk their fucking knees and neck to take down this
asshole.
You know you can get an injury taking a man down.
You sustain for the rest of your life.
Why?
Because some dickhead wants to be cute and ruin a whole baseball game
forever.
But we get me wrong.
If somebody,
if somebody is talking at a movie in a whisper,
I'm just like,
why can't I should I should break their neck like I'm,
I,
I definitely like,
I hate assholes like that.
I can't be fucking around drunk people if I have to like leave my,
like I had to leave Vegas at like five in the morning so there were still drunk
people from the night before.
I fucking fled that city.
Like it was like fucking walking dead.
Like I was just like,
get me the fuck out of here.
I hate people like that and find him,
arrest him,
whatever.
But like when if he died,
which many people have because of the conditions,
but that's some hunger game.
Shit.
Listen,
who don't do that again?
Don't do that again.
He's dead.
Everybody else knows now you can get fucking zap to death if you're an asshole
because we don't need any encouragement for assholes.
Okay?
We need,
this is what I believe.
This is what I believe can stop this whole police brutality problem,
right?
We have to make our relationship with the cops different.
The cops are supposed to be respected members of our community that are there to
help us.
When the shit goes wrong,
it's become because by shitty management and by old asshole con fuck head was
white shirt,
Douche bags that you see punching kids that it all trickles down from the top
and they established the attitude for the younger officers and these guys who go
into the,
into the police academies with good intentions can be corrupted by old jaded
motherfuckers.
Shitty way of looking at people.
I mean,
so many times we have to look at it differently to this us versus them
mentality.
A lot of times comes from people that have a distrust of police from the past or
of of things that they've seen as when it comes to corruption or things that
they've seen when it comes to brutality or they're just a bunch of assholes that
are always doing crimes is they always have to deal with cops.
Go and cut the shit man.
Right?
So it develops that way.
So let's go back.
So like,
all right,
I picked like the most hateable guy by saying I'm the guy who ran the feet.
Going back to like the retarded people going back to kids and shit like that.
It's like because I have met a lot of no way,
no matter what about retarded people that are violent.
You say retarded but I mean you mean downstairs rooms and there were stories of
like and really strong or they have the shirt but they had the mental capacity
of a child and then they have no weapons or anything.
It's just like they're not doing what the cops are telling them to do.
Yeah.
When you see a dude who's like mentally ill and he's lifting weights,
what good can come out of that?
It gets even stronger.
Maybe he could be a superhero.
You shouldn't look,
I don't think you should let him mentally handicapped people if words,
is that a,
is that a bad thing to say?
I'm sure it is.
Probably is right.
It's probably super offensive,
mainly because like,
we're in the kettle bell selling business people,
but I mean,
I don't,
I'm not sure if you want like,
unless they're like really cool,
but if you had them in,
they're really like to have like a conversation with them and just be like,
so kind of music.
Can you,
what do you,
what are you thinking about first dates?
When should a girl put out and it just gets violent?
Oh,
take the kettlebells away.
Yeah.
You can't get any stronger dude.
Um,
what I was gonna say about the,
the white shirts is,
you know,
a,
yeah.
Once you have that sort of,
uh,
versus them,
the US versus them permeates man.
I used to work as a security guard at a concert place and,
uh,
there was like one of the first days I was there,
this guy,
uh,
his name was alley cat.
It was just crazy dude.
He,
uh,
this kid stole a golf cart and they tackled the kid and got on top of him and
beat him with a walkie talkie.
I mean,
it was pretty intense.
And this is one of my first days on the job and I was like,
all right,
I guess I know how shit goes down here guys.
We're not fucking around.
He had a group of psychopaths working for him and that was the whole concert
security.
They were just down to if,
I mean they weren't like assaulting people.
Right.
It was only assholes.
I mean someone had to do some take a swing at them first,
but they were excited to fuck up drunk people that were assholes.
I mean they were,
I mean they never did anything that was illegal.
Everything they did was completely legal for the job.
But our job essentially I got hired,
it was me and um,
nine black belts from my taekwondo academy.
So that was the whole security team.
It was the,
the,
the Taekwondo Academy.
An alley cat.
And he's like buddies,
you're guys competition team and the walkie talkie.
Yeah,
and out,
but alley cat and his buddies were these big fucking hockey player looking dudes
with tough ass Boston dudes and they'd been working in the security business for
years.
They were just down to fuck people up.
They weren't necessarily like martial arts trained martial arts,
but you know,
they knew how to fight.
They were ready to fuck people up.
But so was the most ridiculous setup ever.
These drunk idiot concert goers surrounded by train killers who are led by a
complete psychopath.
Who encouraged you to fuck up people who stepped out of line,
Hey,
rent a cop.
What do you know what their walkie talkie?
Stop it.
Yeah.
Well if you were fucking around man,
he would beat your ass.
Uh,
it was,
uh,
but you develop that mentality.
You've been working there.
I noticed that mentality,
like a real commonplace analogy.
It's like whenever you're a pedestrian,
like walking around New York and you're like,
he's fucking idiot taxis and stuff like that.
And then you're in a cab or a car and you're like,
fucking run him over these asshole pedestrians where it's like,
yeah,
you just get into this fucking mode.
And here's the thing.
Like when we were at NATO,
which like erupted,
um,
for the protest in Chicago,
uh,
the first day the cops were actually like the cops.
I talked to were super chill.
Um,
we're one dude sided ugs tee shirt on and he's like,
where are you trained man?
And we just like talked about,
you see such a common thing with people that,
you know,
if you find someone that trains,
you know when you train it's like automatically it's like,
I know I could probably talk to this guy how long you've been to,
you've been,
you're a purple belt.
Oh,
I,
I've had a,
I've been wearing Jiu Jitsu shirts ever since.
The cops won't beat you as hard.
No.
Right.
I'm worried.
Fortes you bro.
Or it'll just be like an Austin would be like,
you can start and half guard and then I'm going to teach you to dance with my
walkie talkie.
Just don't run on two baseball fields.
That's all I'm saying folks.
So I don't think cops should be tasted old ladies.
We had a fucking,
we had a,
um,
I think in NATO we're actually was a
white shirt that stuck up for my,
my,
my partner has a dozen radio.
My wife is like much more like realistic.
Like,
sometimes I get like idealistic and she's like,
right,
but if you're going to stop being stupid about it and you're like,
I'm like,
oh,
you're right.
Um,
you're more lefty hippie than her.
Uh,
she,
no,
she's just,
she's much more of like a,
I'm kind of like a,
maybe we can all get along and she was like,
or maybe we should learn how to fire a gun.
Well,
you know what,
when you were a woman,
I think,
you know,
dealing with the idea that the other side of the coin is always going to be
stronger.
The other sex is always stronger,
more aggressive,
more dangerous,
and the chances of a woman doing you harm versus the chance of a man doing your
harm are staggeringly different.
So just growing up like that,
I think you automatically,
you go,
you know,
you realize like,
no,
you need a fucking God that you're in a fucking,
you're in a zoo filled with wild chimps.
That's,
that's what humanity,
even with a,
I've got to go back to the story,
but even like,
there's so much shit that like whenever that,
that I just like being a girl,
like if you're a woman,
like you probably can't go to like a family reunion without having your tits.
That,
you know what I mean?
It's like hen thinking about creepy uncles that might've been touched,
you inappropriately squeeze your butt when you were 10 or did something and who
knows what worse or all the kids that you did it too.
You know,
dare you Brian Terry,
I'm cool.
And all I want to do is be the cool uncle.
But I'm like,
man,
too many uncles fuck kids that now there's no cool uncle connotation.
It's all crazy uncle connotation.
Yeah.
I mean you can't look at it as an uncle.
You got to look at as you're their friend and you love them.
And it was a pup fuck labels,
right?
Just cause some other old dude tried to dental.
So a,
so with the NATO thing,
uh,
it was crazy.
So like Alison and I actually got like the closest pretty much I thought this
like white cop,
I thought I liked charmed them.
And what happened was,
uh,
we kept like breaking through the police lines for some reason.
And in New York,
usually what happens is protesters on one side,
cops on one side,
either a protest or moves or a cop moves,
something happens.
The police swarm and they start tackling some kid.
And what was great about New York is there's this like camaraderie among all the
journalists where suddenly you had 50 journalists,
like the cops right here got 50 journalists over taking pictures,
ask them what the kid's name is.
You have the lawyers,
the lawyers guilts would wear hats.
So people knew the lawyers,
they would have rounded up front.
And this is like some old school gangs of New York types was some gang warfare.
Dude,
I'll show you a picture after the show that I have to find on my phone where
it's just like,
it was the anarchists,
uh,
the black block.
And it was a,
just a banner that said,
fuck the police.
And they were here.
And the police were here and some of the cops were like,
Eh,
they don't mean it.
Uh,
but anyway,
so wow,
we're used to the report and it said fuck the police.
I only saw it once.
That wasn't like an occupy thing.
That was like a side like occupy is not hardcore enough for us.
Right.
What do you think about the people that believed that a of that is actually
people that are cops undercover?
They're all,
I've seen it.
You've seen
the instigators or uh,
I haven't seen,
I've only seen videos and read articles about the cops actually being the ones
that started the violence.
What is the,
what does the term for that?
So the tour,
what is it?
Uh,
Oh uh,
agent provocateur.
A provocateur.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
that shit's happened.
I mean I remember just undercover cops,
they're usually like fairly obvious.
We interviewed two that we're convinced really well cause it was just a tall
dude with a crew cut who had a rage against the machine shirt.
And I was like,
come on man.
Like you can't just put on a band shirt.
Like he was like six to like he,
he just,
the only thing that was missing was like his badge and gun and it was like a
raging against it,
but it was like towards more like totally.
And he was with a friend who like looked the same way.
It looks like I have a fucking college wrestler like short,
stocky,
and like he had like a fucking nirvana shirt on it,
which are ridiculous.
And uh,
and so we were like,
let's just interview,
maybe it will be really cool or maybe they'll clearly be cops.
And uh,
this was in Times Square.
So the majority of people there,
the march there wasn't that much.
Uh,
uh,
like they announced it and then it happened pretty quickly.
Like it wasn't like a big month thing where people are going to be flying in and
were like,
so you guys from the city?
And they're like,
no,
we're from A,
we're from Niagara Falls,
New York.
And we just,
uh,
took a bus,
like their story,
it was like really detailed.
Like we took a bus down,
just hit the open road trying to find herself.
And I'm just like,
you're like,
oh,
Jimmy here is getting married next week.
Like it was just like super fucking ridiculous and uh,
you know,
it would be really fun.
Funny a show that was showed is called liars.
All right.
We just have people try to pretend to fit in with like different organizations
like fitted with the occupy and
hey guys,
let's do something violent.
Am I right?
It's fuck the police man.
The fucking police are pigs.
Okay,
let's get all kite on the phone,
right?
Yeah.
Or till up bro.
I'm going to make a bomb.
Hey,
I saw rage against the machine.
I can,
I can view the plants for a palm.
My sprint four G.
Um,
oh,
so you said you saw it.
Some people you definitely believe we're cops will cause you'd see him later and
play clothes talking to the cops.
Um,
wow.
Uh,
yeah.
And so they would infiltrate and trying to like,
well a lot of times,
I mean there are a lot of them,
like I you have,
there's no evidence that they're like place there to be agent provocateurs.
But I mean they are trying to like get information.
I mean there were stories,
the Guardian wrote a piece a little while ago about cops going undercover with
activists and like fucking him,
like just like fucking these girls and like really?
Yeah.
I mean like,
like
a lot of low hanging fruit.
Hippie lost hippies,
dude.
It's like he's,
he's Hippie,
but yet he's still oddly alpha.
What's going on in here?
He smells like Cologne.
A lot of yeast infections going on and then probably a lot of camping.
Yeah.
Hey,
so the cops banging the chicks.
Ah,
how could you stop them?
But I'm like,
everybody likes a little hippie pussy though.
That's where we need,
uh,
our undercover cops.
It was like,
do you remember like during the lead up to the war in Iraq,
it was like,
there were literally groups with peace in the title.
It was like old ladies for peace and they'd be fucking narc showing up.
And it's like,
do pieces on the title,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like there were,
there were there real fucking criminals out there.
Protestors for peace.
Yeah,
right.
We,
we,
we don't want to hurt the Iraqis,
but we really want to hurt cops,
cops,
white,
white cops who crew cuts.
Oh.
So this,
uh,
this dude with this white shirt actually saved our ass.
So,
uh,
he was one of the guys I was talking to the day before and we were kind of
friendly and so we knew I was pressing the way.
We're not saying we want to hurt white cops or crew cuts just for any idiot that
listening to that,
we're pretending we're being a fake character in there.
And they're like,
we're,
we're talking about an idiot thinking that not talk.
Okay,
that is crazy.
You have to preface that shit cause someone can take a fucking sound clip of
that.
And you know,
they fucking hate white cops with a crew cuts this world.
We're living in a world filled with dumb,
dumb,
dumb dumbs.
That's part of the problem.
And some of them get to be cops and it's the real,
the real problem is not cops.
The real problem is just a staggering amount of stupid fucking assholes that are
in every wall.
And it's,
it's,
it's ego too.
We had a friend in New York who used to do like the cycle psychological
evaluations for like the first level for a police training and she would just
tell us these stories where like there was one dude,
I'm to her the exact line if they're caught this,
the question was pretty easy where it was like,
why do you want to be a police officer and taking mine?
Like you're being interviewed to be a cop.
This is like the one,
like if you're,
this is the one time you just,
just don't be crazy.
That's all you have to do to answer that.
Why do you want to be a cop?
That's a stupid protect people all done.
Just don't be crazy for like 10 seconds.
She goes,
why do you want to be a cop?
And he goes,
so I can finally get the respect.
I deserve her.
Oh my God.
What?
It's like,
that's the dude who's gonna fucking curb stomp somebody.
Dude,
he's going to have a second walk.
You thought almost answer ever,
but it's like how crazy are you that you couldn't even stifle that for the
fucking interview,
isn't it Brian?
I guess it was ridiculous.
Fucking so redundantly like ridiculous.
The Dome is answering.
I deserve what?
Fuck some people up.
Uh,
but anyway,
so I hate that because I think that cops are important.
I hate that because I think that there's a real legitimate place for the police
police force.
Of course.
I think you should be,
it should be hard to get into the police force when you were a kid.
I just remember being a kid,
like my perception of cops mainly because of the war on drugs.
I grew up with a car,
my dad was a cop.
Okay.
So no,
I'm very violent then.
Well then my story a little more realistic.
Yeah.
Gee,
well because I grew up in like suburbia and like they would be our crossing
guards and shit like that.
And so I grew up being like,
right,
of course you trust the,
they're here to help.
Like they're always,
and then the older I got like,
and I just see like my friends get like jacked up for having like a dime bag of
weed or like whatever.
Cause it was just bored fucking bully cops.
I don't remember too much about my childhood,
but I do specifically remember my father beating the fuck out of a teenage kid.
Ones.
I forget what he did.
I don't remember the exact details of it,
but it wasn't like murder.
No,
but he picked him up by his hair.
He was a,
he was a scary guy and he was a cop.
So I grew up with that guy.
Yeah.
And it's like,
well,
if that's how we're not really grew up.
So it was like six.
Right.
But that's one of those things where it's like,
fuck man,
if that's how he treats his family,
like what the fuck is going on?
I always assumed,
eh,
growing up like that,
I always assumed everybody was crazy.
I always assumed that everyone,
when you have a father that is has a fuse that's like a half an inch long and
it'll just explode on someone and beat the shit out of someone in front of you.
When,
when you have that you,
you assume everybody has it of course.
So I never looked at cops like,
well this cop is here to protect you.
It was just,
this top could be crazy like by dad outta here.
The people get nasty with you when they,
when they,
you know,
think about how mad people are at little simple things in road rage,
rental,
simple things like you missed your exit and he tried to get in front of them and
they'll fucking honk their horns or mine make it seem like they've never done
that before.
Have you never barely made the exit and tried to cut over and there was enough
space.
It's not like you would a slam on your brakes.
You almost died.
I to do what I was saying.
I was going to the airport,
I was taking the train from Penn station and a I bump shoulders but just as like
fucking just due to suit look like a normal dude.
He was like,
oh,
I'm late.
And he just started screaming and I was like,
dude,
you got to walk away from this.
Like this is like an iPhone.
I've never had that level of anger.
Like the only times I've almost gotten into an altercation,
it was like,
all right,
do I have to defend somebody or do I have to defend myself?
I have a completely different occupation.
If you're doing something that you hate all day,
which is what I'm saying with these cops,
you're running into them,
they're already at nine.
That's a really good point,
right?
Where like a lot of the protesters who were trying to reason with these cops are
just like,
dude,
we are fighting so you can get pension so you're fucking,
benefits aren't going to get taken away.
And the problem with the cops is day she'd be getting paid a shit who was
already turned this off and was like Kilstein hot and it's like left.
Like if their friends around please play this part as well.
Uh,
they should be getting paid so much more fun.
Yeah,
I mean,
if you're getting paid the same manager awarded a shitty retail job,
like of course you're going to be fucking angry and you're like,
I had a friend who I do Jujitsu with who when we first started talking about
occupy,
he's a cop.
When we first start talking about occupy,
he was like,
yeah,
you know,
like I totally support him and you know,
they have the right to be down there and blah,
blah,
blah.
And then by the time it was like three months in and he got dragged down and
they're not making overtime and shit like that,
suddenly a kid runs behind the barrier and this guy was like,
fuck that kid.
Like I'm not even getting fucking paid what I should be getting paid for this.
Fuck that kid.
And then he tackles them and then everyone sees him.
And,
uh,
you know,
a lot of the protesters assume,
well,
that guys is a fucking asshole.
Like
he's the problem.
And it's like,
well,
you know,
he was on your side a couple of months ago,
but he's getting dicked around by his fucking bosses who don't have to be out
there and who are making way more fucking money and who were like,
essentially career politicians,
not even fucking cops.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
it's going to breed so much fucking resentment,
uh,
towards everyone.
But in reality,
it's just like,
again,
unless you're making billions of fucking dollars,
anytime you see a protestor and you screamed,
get a job,
even though a lot of them fucking have jobs or teachers and nurses and they're
just not making enough money or they have a shred of fucking empathy,
which so many people seem to lack nowadays,
uh,
when you see them as like,
they're sticking up for you,
they want to make sure you don't fucking have to,
you know,
suddenly start paying a shit load for,
for Medicare,
for your grandmother,
for,
you know.
Yeah.
Don't putting people in a very unnatural situation and asking them to behave
normally,
both cops and protest.
Putting people in a situation where the cops have to listen to look.
Not every protesters fucking smart.
I don't know how many protestors are saying dumb shit to the cops all day.
The cops are stuck in traffic getting over there.
Their job sucks.
It's a dangerous fucking creepy job being the enemy folks.
It's a dangerous,
creepy job.
Yup.
So there's just,
it's an unnatural position that most people should not be asked to be in,
but I completely agree that cop should be paid a fuck load of money as should
teachers.
Those are two things that is is a sign of a sick society.
If you look at the way we spend money on foreign wars and these I,
this idea of policing places we're never going to fucking visit that have been
that way for thousands of years.
Fuck you to do that and not want to spend money on schools and not want to spend
money on cops.
It's just indicative of how corrupt our society is.
We have the money.
If everybody just worked and used their resources the way that we could w w the
way we would want them used if we used our resources in this country,
the way that people would actually vote on,
if we could all vote on what percentage of money should be put on national
defense,
what percentage should be on education,
what percent?
You would be amazed if we could decide and be amazed at how quickly things can
change,
but what happens is the sign of corruption,
what happens if we don't find the education system?
They may have a shitty education.
More people drop out and then they can join the fucking military and fighting
these doors.
Exactly.
It makes it easier.
I mean that is,
that's the argument.
The argument is that it's weakened on purpose in order to make sure that they're
always have a steady supply of rubes to work for them and do their bidding.
Poor communities for all these people who are like,
get a fucking job.
You know all these people get a job.
It's like because there haven't been jobs and they're fucking community.
They can't buy produce in their community.
They're having been jobs there for years except for fucking drug dealing.
And their dad was arrested for drug dealing.
So then this kid had to take care of his fucking mother,
right?
So then he ends up drug dealing and then fucking he goes to jail and then you
get out of jail and what you're just going to start fucking applying to Ivy
League schools are going to look for like internships in the media business.
Like of course you're going to fucking drug deal cause that's the only way to
put money on your,
to feed your family.
People have to accept it.
Other folks get a real bad roll dice and you start
off on Shit Street and there's not much you can do about that.
But imitate your atmosphere in order to try to get by in life.
And that,
that is a lot of our problem in this world.
It is not the,
the children that are committing crimes under the problem.
It's how these children get into this position where they can commit crimes.
What the fuck is going on?
Well,
what's going on is there's a shit education and there's a fucking shit community
and there's a bunch of people that are constantly involved in crime.
And that is the roll of the dice.
These poor people got,
well,
we have to figure out as a society is how to improve the weakest areas of our
foundation.
The weakest areas of our structure and the weakest area clearly are the areas of
impoverished people that are filled with crime.
We need to fix those.
And if till until you fix those,
you're not really trying to make a better America.
You're just being an asshole.
You're just wasting our tax dollars doing shit that corporations want you to do
because they've paid you.
And that's how they got you in the office.
The,
the heads of these corporations are paying less in taxes than all of your
listeners are.
Yeah.
And,
and that's what's so crazy is they say,
well,
I did this.
It was the free market,
the government to make this job.
Right?
But it's like,
right,
but they paid for the road you took to get there.
They paid for the police that protected your corporation from being robbed.
They pay for,
you know,
maybe your kids went to public school,
but I doubt it.
Uh,
but park,
I mean,
here's the,
here's the real issue that people have,
the people that don't want to pay more taxes.
Here's the issue that people have.
They,
the number one,
the most prevalent point is they don't want lazy people to get free money.
That is,
it isn't it?
And that is a real point.
And that's being ignored by the left and to a certain extent,
because we really do have to look at the welfare mindset because it is a
terrible psychological mindset.
Compare the,
the people you're describing are out there for sure.
There's a lot of on hail in comparison to the amount of kids you were just
talking about.
Uh,
who are the ones who are born into poverty?
And I mean,
here's what I completely agree,
but I don't think that money just pushing money in their hands is the way to
handle it.
No.
But I mean there were people to lazy way of approaching,
but there,
but at the same time it's,
you know,
there was a strike.
Look,
you lose your job for example,
right?
You lose your job,
you lose your benefits.
Right?
Um,
back before the affordable care act,
which I have problems with again for hurting him three [inaudible],
uh,
before the affordable care act,
you couldn't really get health insurance if,
let's say you were sick,
I said you had cancer,
right?
Because that was a preexisting condition.
So now you got fired.
You're not getting any money.
Or maybe even if you are getting welfare money,
but now suddenly you have to pay for your own fucking cancer treatment.
And so then what happens when it doesn't have insurance?
So then he goes to the hospital,
they have to see him and if he can't be,
can pay than the hospital pays for it.
And that like we're just losing more and more money.
Here's the issue with what you just brought up.
You just brought up an artificial scenario.
I can bring you up another one.
So there's a woman,
she never worked.
She keeps having children.
The more children she has,
the more money she gets.
Her kids all become criminals.
No,
they're all being,
me and my wife,
they're all being raised by idiots in a terrible environment and everyone's on
welfare and food stamps and people don't want their money to continue to go to
that.
There's that too.
There's that that you're looking at welfare,
sponsoring a credible organization where it's like,
but I don't necessarily think that sending them a check is the way to do it.
I'm not saying that they don't deserve attention.
They most certainly do.
I have always said,
and I say it on this podcast all the time,
that if you want to make the country a better place,
the first thing you got to do is make sure there's less losers.
So you have to find children and give them hope.
And so you've got to give a kid who you know has got a shit,
roll the dice and give them an opportunity.
And I think there's plenty of people and plenty of resources to accomplish that.
And I think it should be our number one goal as Americans.
If we really truly consider this a tribe and we really are a tribe of 300
million people,
we can't ignore the shittiest part of the tribe.
Now money is not the answer.
Spending money on programs in education and having community centers or giving
them a sense of community,
building up a sense of community,
making sure that everyone has food.
Yeah.
Okay.
Make taking that out of the equation so people don't have to worry about fucking
starving to death.
I'm 100% for that,
but just giving them a check.
I don't,
I don't agree with that.
I think maybe we should set up places where they can all like community centers
where anyone can eat at anytime [inaudible] centers and stuff like that.
But I got want education.
I want,
I want a place where you can go there and there's a boxing coach.
You go,
there's a,
there's a go could teach you Jujitsu.
You know,
like where kids can have something where they can have a positive,
uh,
a place to put their energy and you could develop good human beings.
I mean,
we are,
we are on the same page.
Actually on the same page of helping people that need help,
especially people that just got unfortunate and people that are sick.
I'm 100% I think that should be again,
a part of a tribe,
but don't get all of my friends.
Okay.
In My,
uh,
you know,
what are we call death squad are immediate.
If it,
if any one of my friends was ever in a situation where they needed money for
anything and I have that money,
I would,
I would spend it immediate,
this is why I came here today.
But you know what I'm saying?
Real proposals.
That's how we should feel as a community 100 when we have,
when we have an issue like the,
you know,
the issue with this comic who was hurt in the Aurora shooting house.
Yay.
The comic community is rallied around,
they started,
they're doing a bunch of benefits for this kid and it's great.
Yeah.
And they're,
they're donating money to his family and it's beautiful.
And I mostly do that on a,
on a large scale.
I think she can she answer because yeah,
of course.
You did,
you just like,
you're not told,
you know,
you're not supposed to give,
uh,
homeless like alcoholics money,
so they don't buy alcohol.
You're supposed to take them to a shelter or call a shelter.
Don't give a man a fish.
I do agree.
Don't,
uh,
you don't want those lazy people are getting checks or kettle bells as we
discussed earlier.
Well,
we need,
dude is a shift in the way human beings approach each other the way we're
taught.
We can approach each other and the way that will benefit us.
Yeah,
totally individual.
I think that's why occupy
got so popular because,
you know,
it wasn't just resentment because you're wealthy.
You know what I mean?
I think like Cheo had that quote where he was saying that like,
liberals don't,
uh,
liberals don't like they something like they hate wealthy people.
It wasn't like,
you know,
that it made it more of like,
oh,
we're jealous.
We just don't like you for being rich.
That's bullshit.
If you get rich ethically good for you,
like that's great.
You save that and that's nice and you have a very good point of view.
However,
there's a lot of morons who adopted the,
if you're rich,
you did it off the backs of people we had.
I mean we had,
I've faced it as an entertainer.
I know everything I've done is just tried to make people,
I mean everybody I do for money,
I'm trying to make people the lab trying to explain to you just,
I mean I'm not hurting anybody,
but yeah,
people would be upset at me personally because I've made money.
I had,
I had a couple of people that argument,
I had a couple of people who,
um,
and then I'll get to the positive point,
but I had a couple of people who,
and this is right.
I mean we have,
you know,
tens of thousands of liberal kids who listened to us and maybe this was like
four or five tweets,
but there was so obnoxious that those are the ones I fucking focused on.
Of course I did Conan,
uh,
which have not been invited back.
I talked about drone strikes,
criticized Obama,
and on the same episode like I was like,
I wonder why they got so much hate mail.
And then like the other guests,
it was like something like child star and like Coby Bryant.
And I was like,
oh,
that makes sense.
That's not really my crowd.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
talking about drone strikes did literally everything I could to make it like as
different and edgy,
like just walk the fucking line as close as I could.
And uh,
someone immediately was like,
Yo Bro,
like TBS zoned by this like giant corporation.
And I'm like,
go fuck yourself and die.
Like,
what am I supposed to do?
Like there,
there are occasion there are going to be there like left of left miserable
people who wouldn't be happy unless it was like,
this is citizen radio live from a box in an alley.
Uh,
someone please bring me food.
I'm really hungry.
Uh,
and then they'd be like,
yeah man,
like Che Guevara sold out yet,
which get an apartment.
You fucking sell out around carbon in the backs of your listeners.
Would I send you money?
So you talk and now you get a fucking apartment.
Dude,
really,
I want you to broadcasting from the emergency room for emergency care.
But I used to believe in you.
That's one of my favorite ones.
What they used to believe in and out that shit is you went to a subscription
model,
Jamie Kilstein you fucking shoulder.
We have it as a thing.
I'm like,
dude,
we have made every terrible business decision to not sell out like every
mistake.
We should be homeless a thousand times over.
We still out this shit we love.
Well and that's the flashlights we sell out to on it.
Yeah,
we had one,
we had one sponsor like back in the day that we really like legitimately
supported and like bought shit from.
So we were like sure.
And of course because they were ethical,
they were like,
we can't afford to pay her anymore.
And I was like right on.
You know,
we were going back,
we were talking about the difference between the silent protest being so creepy
and throwing glitter on people.
Yeah.
And I did want to say,
I didn't want to stop your rant,
but I did want to say that I fucking love when they throw glitter on people.
Have you seen the Tom Freeman pie?
No,
I don't like pies,
pies or rude,
but glitter on undercover gay dudes who are mean to other gay dudes.
And that shit is beautiful.
Marcus Bachmann,
man,
when they glitter Marcus Bachmann,
I've been going back and forth on Twitter with the dudes who do it and they send
me tweets and emails whenever they catch it and they throw glitter on them.
They showed up at his place and trust his barberry.
And I fucking love that.
I love that
man.
If you don't know who he is,
is his wife,
Michele Bachmann is at one point in time was somehow or another they thought
that she was going to be like Sarah Palin type character only even nuttier and
they were going to try that out.
But we're not ready for this yet.
We're not ready for a lady who,
not only is he probably thinks the earth is 10,000 years old,
but has a fucking gay husband.
Well,
they have one of those gay,
uh,
like conversion camps that,
yeah,
he runs a prey,
which by the way,
it's like if you're a gay dude and you're looking to pick up guys,
that's great.
Yeah.
Like I pray the gay way camp,
they did one of them,
it was New York Times or Vanity Fair did a,
um,
uh,
an undercover sort of a thing.
Oh yeah.
There.
And they're all like,
guys are hugging you from behind with their boners pressed into your ass.
No bullshit.
And they're praying the gay away.
And,
uh,
so these guys,
I don't remember the name of the group.
I apologize,
but I thought it was fucking awesome.
A bunch of proud gay guys just showed up at Marcus Bachmann's pray the gay away
place,
dressed as barbaric.
And then Lynn throwing glitter on them whenever they see them.
I think that's fucking awesome.
It's,
it's,
it's a high time that that becomes ridiculous.
The two kids that,
um,
uh,
stood up and made out at the two guys who had a,
the Rick Santorum rally came to my show in Chicago and uh,
apparently they didn't plan it.
They just like went like ironically to the Rick Santorum,
Riley and what was so with a gay couple,
it wouldn't be a real protest if they weren't good on that either way.
It just starts sucking each other's do you Santoro your rig?
Check this out,
hail Satan.
But here's what was so funny,
my favorite part about that was,
so they're,
they're like big,
they look like hockey players.
So like they stood up and I was like,
I was like,
are these dudes going to brawl?
Like they were just like these bearded and so they,
so they stand up and they start making out and like the audience,
you hear the audience at first they're like,
oh,
they progressively got more clear.
But then my favorite part is because it was republicans,
they didn't know what else to do so they just turned chanting USA,
USA,
which doesn't even make sense.
Like it looks like.
So essentially all you see is a Rick Santorum rally,
two dudes making out and it looks like everyone is rallying behind and punk and
like America and then a hilarious took a Rick Santorum poster from the rally.
I made them sign it for us
video of them chanting USA while those guys are killing be awesome.
It's the funniest thing.
They should have that for like gay America.
They should have the extent or just show them kissing.
No better.
Yes sir.
[inaudible] oh,
they already contained USA.
What a dumb Chan USA.
This is USA.
You fuckhead USA is gay people too.
That is so down Sarah.
But that's what,
that's what they do when they panic is just like,
we'll cut.
We'll cut through.
Where are we going again?
Right?
USA.
Yeah.
Let's just all be as dumb as possible you,
which just break it down to some letters and we all agree we're on the same
team.
Okay,
where did he go?
What does that even mean?
You can't interrupt a dummy who wants to be king by kissing.
You can't.
You can't interrupt a dummy.
A silly dummy that has no right running the world.
No,
no,
you crazy asshole who believes in old,
ancient stupid shit.
Now you can't run things.
Uh,
and then here comes a kiss that blows my mind.
I was like,
religion is the one thing where like you don't need evidence and it'd be one
thing of like you just like,
like I'm an atheist and like when I first read,
uh,
you know,
the big atheist books and stuff,
there was part of me that didn't want to go around and like,
I dunno,
there was part of you like when you first read something that you had no idea
and you're like,
fuck man,
I've been lied to for so long that you do want to take it to an extreme where
like if you see a kid who was like,
merry Christmas,
be like fuck you,
there's no Christmas idiot and like kick them over and be like,
read Christopher Hitchens asshole.
But like then once you kind of calm down and you know,
you,
if people are going to be religious and let's say not hurt people or just cause
they believe in something and it makes them happier,
it makes them feel whole.
Like that's fine,
that's fine with me.
But the fact that you can make policy without proving there's a Jesus without
proving there's a god you can make policy that hurts actual people like we're
not positive about Jesus,
I'm positive are due to suck cock positive,
positive.
Their girls like Plessy seeing pictures of it.
There's evidence,
there's no picture of fucking Jesus.
There's absolutely a picture of girls eating
mom,
mom
that uh,
well it's,
it's ridiculous that anybody should be able to ever enforce any behavior
patterns on anybody else.
If,
if their choice behavior patterns,
if those behavior patterns don't hurt other people.
If your behavior patterns or you like to push people into the street,
well yeah,
we should fucking vet should be eliminated.
What if you're going to be all going off nom nom nom?
Well maybe it'd be funny that way.
I don't know.
It depends on what you're pushing in the street and we are,
if you're pushing people who are assholes right while while making that noise so
you're doing something good and you're being kind of funny.
The pussy eating punisher and I'll push,
I don't get it the fuck am I saying?
Um,
it's just we,
we,
we have to,
I think we have to look at our model of human behavior and we have to change it.
You know,
my um,
I had a revelation and it became like a bit that's in my act now,
but it really did.
I really did have this revelation on a,
on a boat looking at some dolphins and there was thinking of like how smart
dolphins are and what is it
like to be a dolphin,
dolphin consciousness.
I was thinking how strange it is if it like being a dolphin,
like the way he thinks of himself as exactly the way I think of myself.
We're just trapped in different worlds.
I can manipulate things with my fingers and he has to kill things with his face.
And I thought about like what would it,
would I be him if I was a dolphin?
And then I thought about people and I was like,
wow,
fuck,
would it be if we are literally all the same thing and that we're looking at
ourselves through different life experiences,
we're looking at ourselves with different genetics.
But at the,
if you were that little kid with cerebral palsy,
you would be him.
If you lived his life,
you were born him.
You would be him and if he lived your life he would be you.
And that it's like we are just a unique combination of hormones and life
experiences combined with a soul and the entity,
the consciousness,
the whatever the fuck it is,
right?
It has to go through life and make the decisions.
And how crazy would it be if we could realize that we can be happy if we treat
everybody,
that we meet everybody that we deal with as if it's us living another life.
And that doesn't mean no competition.
That doesn't mean no innovation.
That doesn't mean no competition as far as capitalism.
It doesn't mean,
you know,
we,
we have to rely on some ridiculous commune system where nobody has any rewards.
The symptoms start off just,
yeah,
just don't be a fucking piece of shit.
Don't open by being an ass.
Treat the world as if it's you,
you know,
that is,
I swear to God,
I think that's possible.
I think if you do good work in,
you know,
as long as we have a real economy,
if we have a real market,
if we have,
we really do manufacture things and create things that have merit and we,
if we're really configure that out,
if that's possible.
And that's what makes it a little trickier because I,
I'm not sure if we can really run a society like this without being corrupt.
Well,
the,
you know,
the problem is it's like,
I really don't think that the majority of Americans are like racist,
homophobic pieces of shit.
But a point that Alison writes about a lot is,
you know,
in times of economic struggle,
that's when you see harsher,
uh,
immigration laws come down.
That's when you see more homophobia.
That's where we see more violence because it's always this other,
right?
Because in America you're told you can do whatever you want.
If you want to be a millionaire or if you want to be a successful entrepreneur,
you can do it and then you don't do it.
But you have some politicians,
I'm rich politician who has your fucking money.
You have him saying like,
well,
we just have too many immigrants taking their jobs are like the gays there.
They're angering Jesus.
And,
and then you start blaming these other people because you're like,
it's not me.
Because like there are a lot of republicans who are being fucked just like we're
being fucked.
Just like everyone,
independence,
whatever,
being fucked.
Because,
uh,
and the people who are actually doing the fucking are just like,
well,
don't look at my house.
Don't look at my mansion.
Don't look at my bank account.
Don't look at my fucking tax records.
It's fucking Jose over there.
And you look,
and it's just just like friendly Mexican dude and a pickup truck like that guys
going for your job.
And you're like,
well,
fuck Jose.
Because it's also easier to go after the immigrants than it is to overthrow our
broken system.
Right?
Like if you tell someone that the election was rigged or that votes are being
suppressed or that George Bush and when in 2000,
they're like,
I'm just gonna Blame Nader cause that dude's fucking old.
And that seems easier.
You know what I mean?
It's easier to blame like,
uh,
around policies are to blame a Ralph Nader,
then it's easier to blame an immigrant,
then it'd be like,
oh no,
it's all the people with all the power and all the money and all the guns and
the road maps to the wars.
Like they're the ones we have to like do the wheat.
You know,
we need a shift in,
in the identification of response.
Going back to where I totally agree with you is,
you know,
a lot of people think that like atheists are like these like weird,
immoral,
like we're just like,
but fucking,
I'm worshiping the devil.
Wait a minute.
You know what I mean?
That's like a Tuesday thing,
but not like all we got to,
you got arrest.
Uh,
on Wednesdays been fuck while you sing,
shout you,
but fuck you bought fuck on Tuesday while you praised the devil.
And then Wednesday like Jesus,
it's like,
and then he rested or like that gives me great happiness knowing that for sure
some do to have butt fucked while singing,
shout at the devil shout,
shout,
no doubt about it.
Or they're doing or they're like,
the podcast is over,
we have to do this,
they're going to crank it and bud fuck,
fuck or,
and it's going to be like one of the best days of their life.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a problem with people trying to stop other people from doing shit and,
and,
and you know where that comes from.
It's like fear.
Who's always the Dickhead,
who's going hard,
like way too hard and aggressive,
uh,
against smaller people.
Jujitsu with the dude just sucks.
Did Jujitsu,
who's always the comic who when you get to the club he's automatically like,
just like,
hey a,
it's a gay shirt.
You got the,
where's your wife?
Probably fucking,
he was like,
who the fuck are you and was this Shitty Mc two that is right.
And then you know,
I mean that always happens where it's like the more,
the more of an equal you have because look,
if you look at a statistically we're not handling this marriage thing well this
thing that we claim is like show fucking like sanctimonious and you know,
marriage is one of the institutions of America,
the war.
The majority of people get fucking divorced.
So obviously we're not doing it right,
but it's that same fucking ego,
right?
Well it's like,
well,
I'm not happy so I don't want that fucking gay mother singing and heavy metal
and I was fucking marriage.
Okay.
You have to know to call the phone.
You know,
marriage is between a man and a man and a woman.
You have to be miserable.
You have to surrender all your dreams.
You have to hate your fucking spite kids that you had miserable that doesn't see
it.
No,
I'm saying
what I'm saying.
Those motherfuckers are so miserable.
The ones that have miserable marriages.
I'm not saying it's,
it's an I have a very happy,
and if you really love marriage and you really,
if you really are upset at someone making marriage less than it should be,
why don't you attack those fucking drive through places in Vegas?
We get married by Elvis.
That seems ridiculous.
I mean,
if you want to talk about like not taking a commitment seriously,
the fact that you could do it drunk,
but then you have a monogamous gay couple,
the two together for 10 years and have a kid and they can't get married.
So if one
of them fucking is dying,
the other one can't see him in the hospital bed.
But that goes back to the home,
be right.
That goes back to just not being a dick because again,
it was the idea that there's something wrong with that guy because he likes
something different than you.
Then you like,
it's so stupid and it's something that is,
by the way,
a weakness.
And if you're a fucking man,
you want around,
run around thinking you're a some sort of a bad ass and you can't understand
that someone can have different desires than you,
then you're a pussy,
you're weak or you're confused,
you're sad or you probably get where you're hiding.
Some shit could be some gay shit going on in your past.
Oh,
American beauty,
stabbing and garage always said that there's two types of due to want to stop
gay marriage.
This really dumb people and people that are secretly worried that Dick's are
delicious.
Really,
really gay people.
It's true.
They're just,
they just fucking crib like this chicken guy that's Chick-Filet guy,
he's spending millions of dollars to stop gay marriage.
I guarantee there's some cock in his past,
I guarantee.
And it is not the good kind of county.
The roots,
it has dark calm thing has happened to him.
Even dark,
evil,
not blind.
Either he was molested or he did some molesting or he likes to go to row road
stops because that's the thing is like when like people,
so I,
you know,
maybe not.
I'm going to just be talking shit and was something old,
crazy rich dude spends money probably there.
There has been,
uh,
there has been a,
a dick in his past.
You think so?
I mean I would,
I would say if you had to go to Vegas and you had to look at a good like line,
you know,
I think I would say the Vegas line would be that he's getting is probably had
his dick sucked by a lot of crying and deck second.
Uh,
so because here's the thing,
like there are political issues that I can disagree with people on,
but like,
even though I disagree with them,
like I see where they're coming from where it's like,
okay,
torture.
You think that produces a good result and you want to protect people who may not
be criminals.
Got It.
Like the war,
like you think you're protecting us,
you think that was like Iraq that attacked us.
Like we can disagree and we can talk about facts and stuff like that,
but I get it.
But for someone to wake up every day and be like,
oh,
there are dudes fucking like wells are being sucked in there.
Make that their issue is crazy.
Their defense though,
with a lot of them,
they were,
look,
the real problem with religion is that anybody telling you absolutely they know
what God wants you to do is fucking crazy,
crazy.
Every one of them.
Anyone who tells you,
anyone who wrote anything down,
and that's not taking away from the idea that there's not some sort of a natural
order to the universe.
And maybe there's some sort of higher power consciousness that is at the end of
this whole crazy ride that we're all on.
But when you decide that,
you definitely know that this shouldn't be happening,
even though the people that are doing it or enjoying it because it's some
ancient thing that's just some guy that God wants his stuff.
We have an education problem.
That's what that is,
right?
That is an education problem.
That is a consciousness.
The problem that a problem
with people that have not been raised to accept other people's happiness.
Well and I,
I dunno,
I don't think,
I,
I don't think I've ever talked about this.
I don't think I talked about in your shower or anything,
but like I,
I have,
I started thinking that way since I was naked.
I was more of a Dick.
I was more selfish.
Uh,
when I believed in some kind of God,
I was never like religious.
Like I never went to church.
I never went to synagogue.
I never,
I always knew organized religion.
Here's how crazy religion is.
I even though I was on stage talking about how I thought,
uh,
I,
I consider myself agnostic.
Uh,
which to me is almost like worse than being a Christian.
Cause these Christians are taking a stand.
I'm standing at a stand where it's like agnostics to me are like independent
voters where it's like make up your fucking mind and start losing friends like
me,
like start alienating
people and just be fucking miserable all the time.
World needs agnostics think we need agnostics with almost everything.
But here's what I actually,
I think that most atheists or agnostics,
because like if we're going,
if we're going to be technical and then I'll get back to like,
if we're going to be technical,
anyone who says they're 100% sure that there is a god or there isn't,
God is wrong.
So as an agnostic,
I'm like,
all right,
so I look for evidence and I looked for science and until that happens,
um,
I'm just going to live like there's no god or whatever.
And,
but if right now,
like during the podcast,
like,
you know,
something happened and God came down and I wouldn't be like,
fuck you over.
Read Sam Harris.
You're not real.
I'd be like,
I was wrong.
You know?
No one man,
Sam Harris is a friend of mine and Sam Harris is a brilliant guy,
but Sam Harris doesn't know exactly how the universe works either.
No.
All I'm saying,
yeah,
but just say you're an atheist.
When,
when you see these guys who are these,
um,
these string furious,
this theorist dudes,
these guys who were working on trying to decipher the,
the very matter that,
that constitutes a university,
they're trying to figure out like at the,
at the very heart of it,
what are they're,
they're finding these mathematical computations.
They're finding these mathematical patterns in nature and like,
we know that in the FIBONACCI sequence that in the,
it just,
even the design of faces and sunflowers,
if there's an actual formula,
a numerical formula to all of this,
right,
and they're not exactly sure what that means,
it could mean that there's some sort of a spiritual or guiding energy or ethic
at the end of the unit.
I have the answer.
I have that the meaning of life you're about to get on the show.
First of all,
uh,
the first part of the meaning of life is Sam.
Dot.
Tortures,
tortures,
tortures told me that.
And so it,
racial profiling for Sam Harris.
Sam,
just,
if you're listening,
it's not good.
Is that you're a smart guy.
I love letter to Christian,
Asian,
racial profiling.
Not Good.
All right.
My meaning of life.
Um,
act like you don't know and just be fucking like,
look,
there is more harm in living.
Like there is a god,
then there isn't.
So it's cool to not be sure items in living life there is a,
there is more potential to be harm because I so disagree with people.
Here's what you can
people,
it actually works as a scaffolding and then Christianity and the idea of good
being a good person and being a good Christian and Christian values and,
and treating your brothers if he were yourself,
you know that,
I mean that is in the Bible.
Well,
but something that Sam has sat,
but I bet,
I mean there's also,
you know,
you're going to go to hell if you don't believe Jesus should be slightly for
different types of cloth.
You go to hell.
But I think that like I didn't need the Bible to tell me not to be an asshole.
Like good.
Okay,
good,
didn't
you didn't.
But maybe there's a dude who has a nine volt battery brain and he does,
he needs it.
He needs,
I will look,
you know,
we don't necessarily all go into this life with the same equipment and there's,
there's a lot of people that for whatever reason,
it makes them feel better.
It makes their life better.
The whole ball of wax,
whole ball of Christianity.
What I was saying about the agnostic thing though is so for them,
cool.
Right?
Like they're not hurting anyone if they,
if they don't hate the gays because of it or think,
Oh waw fucking sell as a baby or whatever.
Fine.
Um,
but I think when you're kind of teetering,
like I've seen friends of mine and family members who have act and I've done
this,
who when I thought there was a god I was less charitable.
Um,
really,
totally because there was this newer or less charity because there was a part of
me,
but I was also fucking poor.
We will also,
probably you were young too,
but there was also pump.
But I would tell myself,
I remember specifically like walking by people that maybe now I would give money
to.
Maybe I won.
Uh,
but I'd walk by someone and it'd be like,
well,
God will take care of it.
Right?
Or like oversee.
It's like,
well,
God won't let this happen even though there've been so many wars and plagues and
all this stuff.
And then once I was like,
you know what,
there's probably not a god,
let's just live like there's not one.
Um,
I actually took all those cliches about,
you know,
live everyday like it's your last and stuff like that.
Uh,
I started listening to them where I'm like,
I'm just going to try to be a good person because this is probably it.
And if it's not fucking bonus,
right?
Like if there's a heaven and there,
there's a god and I found out I was wrong,
I'm not going to be like,
fuck you mother fucker and like charge him,
swing it.
I'm going to be like,
awesome because,
and don't get me wrong.
Like I,
when I was,
uh,
when I was onstage making fun of religion,
literally onstage making fun of organized religion,
I still believe that a god,
like I remember,
I consider myself agnostic,
but my wife was the first atheist I've ever met.
And so I was like,
so you're agnostic.
And she goes,
I'm an atheist.
And even though I was onstage criticizing religion,
it's like a match made in heaven.
I doubt the,
the,
the child get together and murder some lettuce and
you don't do that.
You Hunt Christian agnostic and atheist.
But there was part of me in my head that I was just like,
when she told me that I got really scared and I was like,
but you're gonna go to hell.
And like,
I was on stage.
Like I didn't think I believed in it for real.
But like religion was so powerful.
And even if you don't grow up that religious,
we know when you grow up,
even people who consider themselves an atheist,
they still remember just like,
I mean,
threatening the child with hell.
Like that's some scary fucking shit.
Tell me,
man,
I grew up Catholic.
I went to Catholic school for you,
it's terrible.
You will never feel like you're not in the way when you're,
when you go to Catholic Church and Catholic school,
especially like in fucking Harrison,
New Jersey,
like this is some dark shit going on.
There's not a lot of happiness.
There's no fucking sunny days when you get out of that place.
Right.
Oh,
so what,
what I was going to say about um,
beliefs,
people,
right?
So I know people who aren't religious,
they're certainly not homophobic.
I mean,
I'm sorry they don't go to church,
but they believe in a god.
And a lot of times like,
you know,
they've used that sort of as an excuse for like,
let's say they have like a drug relapse or an alcohol relapse.
They're like,
well maybe God had another plan for me.
Or just because someone uses it in a week way doesn't discount them using it in
a positive way.
And that's why I'm saying like if you,
again,
if you're a good person,
cause you're religious or a good person and you're an atheist,
like great,
do your thing.
But when it came to like being an agnostic,
I would rather,
I would rather live like there is no god and I'm like,
I'm just gonna try to be a good person for the right reasons.
Not because I want to get fucking rewarded in heaven where we can see all my
dead cats and eat pancakes or whatever the fuck people think heaven is and not
because I'm scared to burn the hell.
Like I want people to be decent people to be decent fucking people.
Well it makes life nicer.
That's really where it's at.
And I think people don't understand that you can,
if you ever been in a party where you're hanging out with all your best friends
and you know you're sitting by the pools,
some music is playing,
maybe you have a couple of drinks and everybody's having a good fucking time and
everybody's being nice to each other and never,
you know what I mean?
It's like you love having a good party,
right?
Well,
life could be a fucking party stupid.
It really can be.
You just gotta be a nice person and surround yourself with other people that are
trying to be a nice person as well.
Take responsibility for your own fucking actions.
Get your shit together,
contribute your part so that everybody feels good about the interactions with
you.
Give people more than you think they deserve just so they feel better about it.
Yeah.
And if you can do that,
if you could figure out how to do that,
you can have a good life.
This is actually awesome to do that.
Just have that,
cause I wanted to,
to bring this up,
when you wrote that thing on Jujitsu,
uh,
that kind of went viral about ego and Jujitsu.
I actually didn't read it.
I said it or he said,
right when I got my black belt,
I did like a little speech.
The speech.
Okay.
So when that went,
when something printed it and like people started passing it around.
I'm like,
at least Marcello School in New York.
I think like Jujitsu squirrels worldwide.
We're like fucking rejoicing where everyone was so happy about it.
And
I really do believe,
oh,
unless you want me to what I said,
what I said is that it's,
I meet a lot of people through Jujitsu that are really fucking cool and one of
the reasons is that they,
their ego gets confronted with reality on a daily basis.
When you do Jujitsu,
you're,
you're basically battling to the death.
I mean,
that's what you're doing.
You're trying to bar each other.
It's very technical.
You're,
you're trying to use your technique in an intelligent manner.
He tried to pace your body and intelligent manner.
It's a very real scenario.
And when you,
you tap or when you get dominated or even when you,
you defeat someone,
you learn something from the process,
you grow and develop and it is real and concrete.
If a guy taps you,
it is real and concrete.
There's no getting around it.
He got you.
And that was it.
Well,
that's what I love about it.
Where like people don't have that in real life.
And even a lot of like other arts,
like if you're a shitty musician,
you can tell yourself that people don't get you and that you're trying to do
something.
But if you get choked out,
you're just shitty.
You have to tap,
right.
If you're a bad comedian,
again,
you can blame the audience or whatever.
But when it's you who's physically as put yourself in a position where you're
vulnerable to the submission,
someone's locked it on,
then you have to take your hand and say,
I give up.
You know,
there's no talking out of that.
And what's so interesting to me,
especially having like a really liberal base is sometimes,
and this is what I got like the most furious on Twitter or when people were
like,
oh,
you were Vegan but you support human cockfighting,
you support this fucking blood sport sport MMA.
And you know what's so upsetting?
It's like the Vegan argument's ridiculous cause I'm like,
yeah,
totally man.
All of a sudden things a vegan chickens don't get fucking fighter of the night
over war [inaudible] six days without they shit.
Right.
Should I just fucking can suck it?
Give the,
give them a shot against the farmers.
Just,
all right,
you can try to fight your way out.
Chicken.
Uh,
but fucking,
but what's so interesting to me is like the hardcore lefties who come at you for
your interest.
We're,
I guess we're not really a hardcore lesbian.
You're fine.
Really fucking negative people.
But here in every walk of life,
it's so interesting tying into what you wrote is like,
so this week I competed in Ibj f and he won a bronze medal.
Right.
It was my first competition.
That's awesome,
man.
I turned 30 and I was,
I'm gonna Start fucking competing.
What Bell to you?
I'm just biased.
Got My blue.
I only started doing g like last year.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
You just got your boom,
boom.
I got it.
Like,
dude,
whatever you do,
man.
A police stick to that.
I know you were trying to do some,
some,
some Thai boxing and stuff.
Oh No.
I had like the one Thai boxing fight.
It went great.
And I'm like,
I don't want him to win.
Awesome.
That's beautiful.
But I was like,
popped up.
I was going to hurt,
you know,
I'm better at more time.
I don't even really like training anymore.
I just loved the reason.
I love Jiu Jitsu.
I just love Jujitsu culture and kind of so well you know what,
in retrospect or,
or rather a comparison,
um,
I grew up in a kickbox and culture I grew up with and Muay Thai and boxing and
taekwondo and it is a more douchey world.
Yeah.
The reality is because first of all,
you don't spar hard every day.
You don't go out and every day and in Jujitsu you got it every day.
Well that's kind of your day.
You're resisting getting tapped one and lots of times you don't spar at all and
you just do pad work and it's a glorified cardio kickboxing class.
And when you do spar,
you don't go full out.
Right?
No you're not.
You shouldn't,
you certainly shouldn't.
If we were supposed to spar and I tried to attack you,
I would be an asshole.
You'd be like,
dude,
slow the fuck down.
Right.
Cause you're not learning anything when you're going to war like that didn't do
it is just covering up.
And I rarely have to say that in Jujitsu and kickbox and I've had to be like,
tell me if we're in a real fight because if we're in a real fight,
I'm going to hit you as hard as you're hitting me and people hitting you in
Jujitsu.
Oh No,
no,
no.
And kickback where it's,
yeah,
the level of spasm because in Jujitsu I welcome spazzes because you need to know
that a guy can do that using the is using leverage and being smaller and like
getting around that.
Not even that.
I mean someone going fucking crazy using all their might right away,
which a god good God never does.
No good guy.
We'll lock up to you like maybe 30% and then you start moving with each other
and he's looking for advantages,
but he's not gonna do anything stupid doors and kick some ass more than Marcello
Garcia black belt.
Uh,
and he,
he,
and I'll just do this thing where you literally feel like you're like,
am I,
because there's,
it's just like gumby arms and you're like,
am I about to get a lock up?
He's on my back and like you don't even know how it happened.
And there was zero fucking strength used.
Uh,
well what I love so much about it is,
so I trained with Marcello in New York,
but because the competition was in Las Vegas,
um,
I went out to Robert Drysdale,
his place and Drysdale is like super political,
one of the smartest guys I know,
one of the best Jujitsu players in the world.
And there was part of me that was nervous,
like,
you know,
cause I didn't know how politics works.
I don't,
I've only started really traveling and training and at other schools.
So I had like my Marcello Garcia key cause was the only fucking Gi had,
you know,
Drysdale is fucking fought Marcello.
And not only did him and the people my age and the people who were at my belt,
and the people who may at the time didn't know we're going to be competing in my
division,
but they just instantly treated me like such a fucking family member.
I mean,
Robert Cornered me and I go,
dude,
I have like Marcello's Gee,
I'm like registered under.
And he goes,
I don't care.
He's like,
you're my fucking friend.
I'm going to corner Gail.
And he cornered me.
And what's so funny is if people walked by that school or if those lefties on
Twitter or not even left,
he's just people who don't get MMA,
um,
who call it a bloodsport.
Maybe if you walked by during a sparring session,
you'd be like,
wow,
it looks fucked up and scary because dudes are like jumping on each other's
backs and driving each other into the walls and shit.
But when you go in there,
I'm like,
there was more camaraderie there that I've experienced in comedy that I've
experienced and a lot of these like liberal get togethers.
And what's so ironic and so frustrating,
and maybe this goes back to maybe this is what people need to do to treat people
decently.
It's like there are people of all fucking nationalities,
religious beliefs,
political beliefs,
strengths,
weaknesses,
builds and you fucking roll with someone for the first time.
If you've just met someone,
you shake their hand and you have like a killer role,
like a back and forth and we can both of you almost submit,
you'd like just to scheme and the bell rings.
I'm hugging that dude like he's a fucking long lost relative.
Oh yeah man,
you don't think twice about it.
And,
and it pisses me off to no end that that is how beautiful and wonderful Jujitsu
is.
But some people see it and they're like,
it's fucking bloodsport.
I thought you were living with violence.
I see what they're thinking.
What they're thinking is in a perfect world we
shouldn't need violence.
And they are scared of people who are enthusiastic about my loans.
They think it's dangerous.
Sure.
And they're scared of people who actively train in something where you're,
you know,
what you're actively trying to do is figure out a way to harm someone via
Keller.
You know,
they're,
they're thinking from an evolved mindset and I totally agree with it.
However,
I'm stuck with this monkey body.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm a belt like a fucking chimpanzee and I have testosterone,
my system.
Sorry,
Emma's off.
Yeah.
Well what it is is you're,
you're,
you have a fucking ancient body.
We have these bodies that are 10,000 plus years of,
of whatever we've been doing.
That's how our DNA is designed to operate and what reward system we operate
under.
We have like fucking needs.
And one of the needs is men have a desire to prove themselves constantly.
Whether your need,
when do you want to exist in our society or whether you want to,
you know,
whether you want to try to make it out on your own.
Whatever the fuck you're trying to do.
One of the,
your main desires to stay alive,
one of your,
your main focuses is that men have this desire to do at least something special
to stand out.
I went to yoga once for the first time,
it was like that hot yoga,
which is like a fucking nightmare.
It's fucking awesome.
And there was a dude in the class and instantly I'm like,
all right,
all right mother fucker,
like,
let's do this.
And I was like holding the pose incorrectly,
like longer than like I should have just hurting myself.
And then,
and then whenever like I'd stop and I'd fuck up my parents,
they get my head and be like,
what kicked that guy's ass?
Like,
yeah,
there is that fucking bail testosterone.
It is dumb,
but it's also necessary for competition and it's necessary to get better.
It's the,
the thing is you have to learn to get good at it and you have to learn to get
good at it with your ego.
And that's where Jujitsu comes along.
You develop a healthy respect for competition.
I read Mark Marin was talking once about,
uh,
not being able to,
when he was growing up,
uh,
if,
if you wanted his parents to instill anything in him that they did is be able to
enjoy competition.
Cause he said he grew up and if he was losing a game,
he wanted to flip the board over.
He's like,
that was his tech mark.
Marin didn't take losing well named Mark Marin.
That I,
I mean,
that explains so much,
right?
I mean it really does about that that dude's interactions with people.
It's like if someone had just taking him to a,
you know,
some,
a Jujitsu class early on in life and allowed him to experience what this is like
a losing as a normal part of life.
If you don't want to get better,
well then you know,
you're not gonna.
If you don't want to get better than you,
you're not going to take any chances.
And if you don't take any chances,
you're not going to get better.
You take chances,
you're going to fail and you have to fail in order to learn how to move forward.
Well,
I was a,
I was training with,
uh,
with Keith Loria,
Kenny's brother in Boston,
and we were talking about ego and you know,
the times where you're like,
don't want to tap and stuff like that.
And he was like,
dude,
if you're not tapping,
you're not learning.
And Yeah,
I've heard lots of juices.
Do you guys talk about that?
And
I love that.
I love,
uh,
I love a culture where like,
you're encouraged to like take these fucking risks.
Uh,
and,
and that you learn.
You know,
when I lost to the Kitty one silver and I really was,
I mean,
it was a really close match,
you know,
I lost and like I was bummed out for like a second and then I was like,
went over to Robert and Mike.
I was like,
what happened?
Like,
what could I have done?
And he told me and I wonder if fucking wrote it down.
And I was like,
all right,
next time.
That's what it's all about.
It's in competition is good.
Look,
there's a lot of guys that I know that can tap me and I like rolling with them.
And I loved getting tapped.
I like to know what they're doing that can get me,
Oh,
do you?
When someone hit me with like an awesome,
like crazy mood laughing,
she's like,
what?
Just had just felt some dude and my back.
And then we rolled over twice and suddenly like,
he has like my arm,
like attached to my leg.
And I was like,
what?
What is this Jamie?
When are you going to fight Daniel Tosh?
What?
I think a download.
I heard,
uh,
he's not the easiest guy to the pin down.
He doesn't,
uh,
I believe you're not allowed to make eye contact with him.
What did it happen?
How the whole thing before we get to that,
why were you trying to fight some dude who was a,
a congressman or senator?
Chuck,
hold on,
let's back that up.
Since it's on a tape.
I was not trying to fight a senator.
Uh,
I was this conservative pundit name named Jonah Goldberg.
And you want to go to Burger?
Sorta like the stereotypical fucking huge out of shape.
Bully Republican goes on every fucking news broadcast advocating that we just
kill more brown people and,
but has never served,
really says we need to kill more brown people,
but we need to invade Iraq and we need to write a bold mother fucker and invade
Afghanistan and invade all these,
uh,
Brown ish places and uh,
it's fucked up and no one ever,
I mean,
people call him on his shit,
but like no one really costs money shit.
Like for example,
he still has a career even though Iraq and Afghanistan failed.
Like my,
my,
my whole thing is if you advocate a war that has killed hundreds of thousands of
people,
it's killed thousands of Americans.
Uh,
at the very least you should have to like,
when it comes to like the news sit,
the next wore out,
you know what I mean?
Like a fucking baseball player fucked up.
Just like sit it out.
Or at least like if he's going to go on TV and talk about how we need to bomb
Iran,
like under his name,
it should be like Jonah Goldberg,
Dude,
who was wrong about Iraq.
You know what I mean?
Because you know,
he just,
you saying he was wrong about a rack,
but they do Hollywood math on it and they'll tell you that it was a success for
democratic societies all over the world because we removed and evil dictator and
they,
they have a system in place that look how many are more superior or dictators
are,
look,
how many people died looking at my knee.
I mean the place is a shit storm.
Uh,
well I'm not saying that,
but what I'm saying is that a guy like that is never wrong in his eyes.
If you listen to conservative talk radio,
which I do all the time,
just to go crazy.
I listened to Patriot on,
on serious,
so they call themselves a Patriot radio.
It's so bad.
And it's just one dumb idea after another dumb idea about,
you know,
Christianity,
God's
law in this world and oh well,
and,
and the thing is like,
we also have to remember,
let's say even Iraq was a perfect society.
That's not why we went there.
We went there because under the rule of law we said we were attacked.
Uh,
are we set a rack was responsible for nine 11.
I mean,
we didn't even go over there so that it's the same with Iran.
You know,
the people who want more with the Ron aren't saying we want to make a,
a democratic society.
They're saying these are the same people who hailed the Iranian revolution.
They're saying that,
uh,
we are a threat or they are a threat to Israel,
so we need to kill these guys.
And so he gets it.
This guy is talking all this shit bill called liberal fascist and he just gets
to keep going on the news,
keep writing books with incorrect information.
So one day he's,
he's shitting on young people.
He's saying that young people are stupid.
You should raise the voting age.
And you know,
he's right are odd.
Some young people are stupid you and a lot,
and we should take as young people,
we should make them read.
Of course,
you shouldn't have to,
maybe with electric chair tied to with a Taser video game,
every time they pick up a video game with you,
once they've read 10 bucks,
they're allowed to kettle bell and man get a battle rope if you read three.
Right,
right,
right.
And so he said that,
uh,
he said something,
he said he was joking.
He probably was,
maybe he wasn't a where he goes,
kids need,
uh,
these kids,
you'd have to socialism beaten out of him.
And he used the word beaten out of them.
Now you would say again,
me and you listening to that,
we wouldn't be like time to go beat some kids,
but there was a congressman who,
uh,
who last week said that,
you know,
Muslims are still threatening us every day.
And in his district,
two mosques were attacked.
Right.
So it's like to crazy people,
this shit resonates.
But even if it didn't resonate,
it was just another example.
One is a big difference from kids and a religious factions been known to have
suicide bomber still no,
sure.
I mean would be smacked,
right,
of course.
But it was another example because cause he,
cause he's someone else who has it,
who actually has said,
you know,
the Muslim stuff.
So there's another example of just him.
And so all I did was I tweeted him and I said,
hey man,
uh,
so I just about socialism,
I'm socialist e and clothes.
I'm not really a socialist.
Uh,
but you know,
close enough,
I'm 145 pound Vegan.
Uh,
there's sort of several tweets,
you know,
the joke about how do you tell if someone's Vegan?
Well,
I'll,
what is it you or they'll tell you wait.
They'll tell you.
Yeah.
Uh,
but I was like,
I was like,
he'll hate it.
He's one of the guys who compared,
uh,
who was like,
Hitler was a vegetarian and called Vegetarians,
which by the way,
me,
first of all,
you didn't expect this guy was really going fight you.
Well,
here,
here's what I wanted.
Again,
I was talking to my wife,
to Alison and I was like,
maybe he will write.
And she's like,
here's,
he was either situation.
Oh,
so to finish I wrote a whole piece for one cat about it and happy to post
interviewed me.
And essentially what I said was it can be regulated.
We'll do it for charity.
You have about a hundred pounds on me,
I know how to fight,
but you can wear head gear,
I won't wear any head gear,
it'll time rounds,
referee,
I'll give it to Palestinians.
You can buy like an iron ran fuck doll or whatever you guys do with your money
and it'll be great.
And I never ever was threatening or anything like that.
And of course it was tongue in cheek in the sense that one of two things could
happen.
He could be fucking crazy enough to do it,
which I doubted because again,
you look at all these war hawks and these are people who have never served and
worse who are sending their kids to go back or he's going to have to respond and
just be exposed for being a fucking chicken shit.
Which is what he is.
He's a fucking chicken shit.
I like you Jamie,
and that's why I'm going to tell you this.
I think it was a really dumb idea
because first of all,
you opened up the gate and you said you would like to enact violence on him and
kickbox with him.
You know he's not a skillful at it.
Agreed upon.
Let me read upon by saying it's not fair.
I'm helping him in an hour.
Even if he's,
even though he's a hundred pounds heavy in you,
if you're a skilled fighter and you are,
and you've been training for a long time,
that's not fair.
Not only is it not fair,
it's kind of creepy.
It's Kinda creepy.
Hold on a second,
man.
For Real,
as a,
as a martial artist,
but you're,
you're not picking on another martial artists.
You're picking on someone who you know is completely athletically inept.
Someone who I know is not going to take the fight.
It doesn't then don't do it because then you're,
you're opening up the gates to someone wanting to do that to you now.
And then the next thing is,
look,
you're lefty Vegan socially Steve Bullshit is,
I've had enough of it.
You know,
I'm 185 pound meaty there.
How about I come smash your fucking face in,
right?
And then you know,
why?
Why is,
why is that happening?
Why is that happening?
Because you open up the door to challenging someone to a physical confrontation
with violence.
And that's what kickboxing is.
Whether it's agreed upon or not,
that is what it is.
I mean,
we be honest with you,
we're not even,
you're not even talking about Jujitsu.
You're talking about kickboxing.
And let me tell you something,
man.
You know,
you,
if you're in a fight and you're gonna hurt somebody,
you're going to try to kick them and you to try to punch them with all your
mind.
You're talking about assaulting a guy because you disagree with them.
I have had so many people in real life challenge me to fights after shows,
people that I could take if I was an asshole and,
and,
and have new.
Sure.
You sure that you can take them.
I know by looking at it were some,
there were some are aging people and there was a range of people that could
wrestle some tiny fucking shoot a double on you and smash your face.
You'd be shocked.
Wrestlers are the bane of my existence.
Be Shocked at how many people out there who could kick your ass.
So how do you know?
You look at you shit too.
I'm like these like fucking five,
two Brazilians who are like these like crazy black pouts.
I yeah,
but that's one of the reasons that I would never,
I would never fight.
You could take them,
but you're being nice.
And I'm saying you don't know.
Of course I'm silly or I'll get the shit kicked out of them.
So one of these things are happening.
Neither of them are great.
Um,
if I get the shit kicked out of me,
even worse,
you get in the fucking grueling drawn out brawl.
We're no one can get in and he doesn't want to quit and you just,
you got to keep going,
but does this make it on youtube and give me more Twitter followers,
whatever else.
Yes,
of course.
I wanted a,
I wanted to point this out first before I went to the Taj thing.
I definitely want to hear,
so here's what I want now,
but I wanted to,
obviously
this dude is not going to take this fight.
Obviously we're not going to fight obviously,
and in the hole in the article I wrote,
I was like,
I'm not encouraging a society of violence.
I don't think this is how you handle problems,
but I just wanted him to have to respond where it's like,
if you are going to be the one who starts the violent rhetoric,
because at no point did I say I challenge you to a fight.
I said,
if you want to beat a socialist,
GI will volunteer.
I understand,
but do you not understand that that is a,
it's a goal layering like ego situation.
You are putting yourself in this champion role.
Like you are going to step in and you are,
you're putting so much attention on yourself with a statement like that and
it's,
it completely changes just your opinion of what,
what you feel is wrong with his stances.
And it becomes a personal thing between a man and another man who lives in a
different way.
And it,
it's,
it takes the attention away from the issue and it puts the attention on you as
some sort of fucking Kim carnation figure.
And that's,
it's the,
it's not the right way to approach the problem was no one,
it was the first time that these fucking remarks and things got attention
because anyone can get attention.
It got attention amongst us.
It didn't get attention in the real world.
It was a publicity but it wasn't going to get.
But so you're saying by him using that violent rhetoric and being able to use
it,
uh,
ad Nauseum,
it never been called in it like that's also a publicity stunt.
And all I wanted to do was draw attention where it's like,
look,
I did not start the violent rhetoric.
Violence was never going to happen.
It was just strictly a point that it's like,
all right man,
well if you're going to go on and threatened kids,
right?
Really threatening kids is a complete figure of speech.
They need the they,
how many people have said that these idiots today,
they need the fucking sense slapped into,
well he said,
don't advocate slapping,
settle to make us smarter.
Is that physically?
And then he paused and he goes,
or literally and again better,
but in many who just completely absolved it.
The way we see that and we're like,
of course,
like I said before,
you're not going to fucking do it.
But I mean you look at some of these fucking crazy people,
you look at like the moss story,
you look at,
um,
you know a lot of these fucking like right wing militia types.
Like they're looking for people to fucking give them permission to do it.
You look at the abortion clinics and of course I did not think I was going to be
the fucking hero.
There's going to be a fight.
I was going to make this guy change all of his views.
All I wanted was finally someone just to be like,
if you're going to use this violent rhetoric,
just like if you're gonna use this violent rhetoric in the Middle East,
go fucking over there.
But we'll say it to one of their faces.
Go say it to someone who can actually defend themselves,
but I don't think that's violent rhetoric.
I disagree.
I think it's a figure of speech.
His career was the violent rhetoric and that was just the one where I'm like,
okay,
I can say I volunteered to be the socialists in the tongue and cheek fashion.
I really think you should never do that again and I really think that wasn't
going to be like my bit from now on or am I going to be the guy who challenges
people would only reason why people do it.
It's for their own ego.
I mean you're,
you're involving your own ability to do something,
your own physical athleticism in with some debate.
It totally doesn't belong.
When you do something like that,
it becomes a,
uh,
an almost indefensible publicity style is one of those things though when it's
like you're introducing yourself into an argument and be sure you're,
you're even involved in the debate,
but at the same time,
like people have to do that.
Like people have to,
not to that extent I'm saying,
but people have to,
if,
if there are people in the world who keep us housing and violent rhetoric,
that does have consequences,
that does lead us into wars,
that does get people hurt.
I'm not saying go challenge people to fights or anything like that,
but sometimes you do have to do something to draw more publicity than like if I
just tweeted him and I was like,
hey man,
that's fucked up rhetoric.
Or Hey,
I don't think we should have gone to Iraq.
It went to got an as much of the attention as it did.
Um,
and so like sometimes you come through,
you're,
you're saying you came close to missing,
you know,
it didn't accomplish anything.
You're,
you know,
you're saying,
well,
you came closer to miss some of this,
but it was a shot and he had to respond.
And he finally like,
you know,
you've seen a point.
Yes,
100%.
Does it make you embarrassed?
A little bit,
but at the same time it's like,
I guess I just want an answer of what to do because I don't like that people can
go on publicly and make livings out,
uh,
with rhetoric that gets people kill.
I agree.
Get people hurt.
Go.
It's like,
sure.
Mine was a silly publicity start from a comedian,
right?
Did I think Jonah Goldberg and be like,
Oh,
you know,
I'm gonna open up a shelter for Arabs because you know,
that Vegan showed me the way,
but you didn't even act as a,
is someone who was protesting his point of view.
You almost act like a heckler.
Someone to introduce yourself into the equation,
your own physical prowess into the equation of,
listen,
if you think you're a bad,
I'm going to represent socialists and I'm going to
my rhetoric because my rhetoric was the same height or bottling.
Yes.
What if he said yes?
He goes,
come on man,
you little Vegan Pussy,
let's fucking fight and then you're going to find them.
Represent them.
Really have here is that intuit.
We rarely do it.
I had had gear on a chair for charity if he was that into it.
Do you see how that's kind of gross?
Of course,
but that would never have it's but as the exact same as someone writes a blog
post,
someone writes a response,
blonde phone is right.
I just used that hyperbolic language of fighting,
which he was the one who introduced into the conversation,
so it's not really though.
He was talking about children having the sense smacked into them,
which has been said throughout history but not Gan.
Again,
to figure was the history of violence,
violent rhetoric.
I understand.
And so that was just something where I was like,
it's hard like people to grasp that you know,
that right.
When you respond to one thing in particular,
it better be warranted because people aren't going to take into account the
history of someone's,
you know,
Wa,
obsession for violence.
But I mean,
it ended like,
I thought it would end where it was like it didn't begin.
He had to respond.
It was funny.
Uh,
no one got hurt.
No one took it seriously.
Uh,
and it was just kind of like,
let's
just remind people that this guy who has such authority and would go on the news
with such authority,
without people even asking followup questions,
even being like you said the same thing about Iraq.
Do you think Iraq was a success?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
I mean,
she was a guy who said they would be celebrating
to eat.
You threatened to fight and culture.
That'd be a more fair size contests.
I think Daniel Tosh,
you get refereed.
You ever again here?
He doesn't even like Daniel.
Well,
no,
it sounded just like Daniel talks to that we have to talk about,
you tweeted a bunch of Shit that infuriated comedians when Daniel Tosh said,
uh,
to a woman,
she was uh,
she yelled out,
if you don't know the whole story,
this is the exact story.
Tosh is on stage and he was talking to the audience about,
you know,
what should he talk about next?
And someone yells out rape and he goes on,
he starts saying,
oh yeah,
like that's funny.
And like,
uh,
what's,
what's funny,
the humiliation,
what is it to violence?
He's,
he goes on this rant of all the things that are unfunny about rape,
at which point some woman yells out,
actually nothing is funny about rape,
right?
Like to stop this conversation now,
just all self righteously.
And he goes,
wouldn't be funny if like five guys raped right now,
which is the comedian thing to say in that scenario and is in no way endorsing
rape or rape of this woman.
But he had just gotten done in her thick fucking stupid head.
He'd just gotten done saying all the things that are wrong with rape and she is
so on.
Ironically arguing with him,
still saying actually nothing.
It's funny about rape.
She's a fucking idiot.
And then she goes online and writes a blog about it,
a huge dumb,
stupid diarrhea of the brain blog about what had happened when she heckled
Daniel Tosh.
And he happened to say the one thing that a comedian would say in that scenario
when he's saying all these terrible things that are what things are horrible
about rape and saying,
of course he can't joke about rape because it's nothing funny.
And then she self righteously Energex actually rape is never funny.
And he goes,
wouldn't it be funny if five guys raped her?
Okay.
That that is what started off.
And you defended that a woman,
right?
So man,
he didn't like,
if you didn't like the Jonah Goldberg thing,
prepare to be furious.
Uh,
it's always like such a wild adventure on Twitter after I do your show,
cause I got half people who I'm either friends or they will be fans for life as
I bro,
I'm like a Jujitsu guy and like I'm really progressive and blah,
blah,
blah.
And then there's like,
Hey,
uh,
Vegan,
Queer Homo.
I worked for Blackwater and I'm going to shoot you because I love her rape
jokes.
And it's like,
oh no.
So I'm about to get their lodge here.
Here's what I think.
If you talk to me
five years ago,
maybe even less,
I wouldn't have even thought about defending the Heckler,
especially because I have been heckled my entire career.
I'm like,
I think the youtube clip of me with the most hits is me berating meanly,
uh,
a guy,
a girl Hackler on my new CD.
I had four due to heckled May.
And like it,
it's a track I just like attacked,
attacked,
attacked.
Um,
and you know,
when all I thought about and when all I obsessed with and when all I listened to
was comedy,
that was always the most important thing to me.
Right.
It was the freedom of speech,
which I still believe in.
Um,
it was no one's sensors,
a comedian.
You can make anything funny,
which I also still believe,
and uh,
that was it.
No matter how offensive,
whether it was the Dane Cook Aurora joke,
whether it was Tracy Morgan,
the murdering the gay kid thing.
Like it's just like,
dude,
comedy is comedy.
They're experimenting.
Maybe it wasn't funny,
but whatever.
Um,
but just like in like a political debate,
you know,
if you disagree with someone,
he challenged him to a fight and then you get yelled at.
If you disagree with someone,
you should respond.
Right.
And I'm talking about the girl I'm talking to me right now and then we'll talk
about the girl who I also does not sound like she would be a lot of fun to hang
out with.
Um,
and so ever since kind of doing more,
I'm reading more politics and comedy and getting involved in just different
communities that weren't comedy,
whether it's Jujitsu,
whether it's,
uh,
politics,
activism,
whatever,
um,
you know,
as much as comedy,
I love the arts so much.
It wasn't this like defend to the death thing as much because I saw that the
world was like bigger than comedy.
I think there are a lot of comics who think that like this is it.
It's all about the comedy community,
you know?
And this is all we got.
No matter what we do,
we have to like defend our own.
And that's a pretty absolute stance to take,
um,
in this particular situation though.
Well,
so,
well,
here's what I was to say.
So here's this,
that's not what anybody is saying.
No,
you're,
you're sort of building up a straw man defense.
How so?
Well,
you know,
by saying that,
by having someone who's arguing already the point that comedy show,
that's not new.
What anybody's saying?
No,
no one has a right,
I'm describing exactly what I used to do,
what I used to think.
I mean me,
100% May.
Okay,
so you used to think this way,
you,
you're holding that comedy is most important,
more important than people's happiness or feelings.
Fuck you.
Comedy comedy's more important.
All I knew was comedy when I was not good at comedy.
Now you disagree and what do you disagree with you?
So you think that now a woman should be able to say something stupid old
hecklers.
I hate hecklers.
I think you supported her.
No.
Over Daniel Tosh and you said,
here's what I said,
here's how portal heckling before you support rape culture.
That's what she said.
Yes,
100%.
Okay,
but what does that mean?
So I was heckled for people who like make it like a free speed tissue.
Of course he has the right to say that.
Uh,
just like,
like
he doesn't just have the right to say it.
It was the thing to say that was funny.
It's shortly we believed in it.
It's not like we believed he really wanted people to rape her.
Of course he was saying something ridiculous and quick.
Of course that offers top,
where's his head?
Of course not right.
But 100% agree with it.
100 did you tweet?
Which you tweeted saying that because
when there are one in four girls who had been sexually assaulted or raped,
and those are just the ones that are reported,
right,
because it's the most unreported crime we have because largely,
uh,
people don't,
a lot of people don't take it seriously.
There's a lot of victim blaming.
There's lunch.
I wish it was really accurate to describe how many people don't report it,
but unfortunately it's not.
So when you say one in four,
there is a lot of fuckery when it comes to numbers like unreported crime.
So let's not,
and by the way,
I'm not saying this in that people are not being victimized.
They unquestionably are.
Right.
I'm saying that when you get into weird numbers,
like unreported numbers is a reason.
Those are the,
those are the reported numbers one and four is reports.
One,
of course we're 25% of all women had been raped or sexually assaulted.
Real.
It's actually,
it's true.
are you sure about that?
Punch it up.
Okay.
What percentage of women had been sexually assaulted and a lot of them,
uh,
and enough
and a lot of them,
uh,
you know,
we all probably a,
at least statistically know someone who was,
there's probably someone in the audience who was,
and you know,
Daniel Tosh,
I think comedian should push boundaries.
100%.
It's close.
It's one in every six.
It's 14% one.
And every sex,
the one I saw 13%,
it's a lot and 0.8% attempted rape.
There's a lot of dudes suck at rape and uh,
there's a lot of pressure.
You giggled.
That's fucking,
that's,
and you made a,
a tagline to it,
that's rape jokes.
Highs contributed to rape culture.
Not In fucking MSNBC.
It talks about I need 15 minutes on rape last night.
But do you see the,
that which you did by saying that the,
you would rather someone heckle you then then contribute to rape culture.
What the fuck is rate?
So I still have to explain this.
So if we're gonna talk about freedom of speech,
I in Texas,
uh,
had a dude literally run to the stage.
It was my closing bit too.
All you need to do is wait 10 fucking seconds and say if you keep,
I closed on a thing against the war is said,
if you keep doing that,
I'm gonna kick your ass.
So that's actually like violating freedom of speech.
This girl fucking heckled,
the dom heckle and she left.
This dude is saying,
if you keep talking,
I'm going to kick your ass.
Right?
And I wasn't like,
oh,
we should have got fucking shot in Iraq.
Right.
I dealt with how the situation was weird.
Um,
and then,
but this is your situation.
Let's not confuse the issue by bringing in a whole nother story I talk about,
I just want to preface it that I fucking low with hecklers and it,
I've been heckled my entire career,
not just heckling.
You were threatened by it,
but I've also been heckled.
I've had shit thrown at me.
You know,
I'm not a fan of body and mind is you support that woman because to me with rape
culture is the fact that
because rape is dealt with so lately in this country,
um,
lots of women don't report it.
Lots of Roman don't report simple sexual assault.
Fucking dude comes up,
grabs your tits at a club because she doesn't want to be called a slut.
She's want to be called drunk.
She doesn't want to defend herself when she feels like she was assaulted.
Right.
And so to me in that moment,
as much as I care about comedy,
you know,
when I started reading a lot of progressive blogs,
when they talk about rape,
there's something called a trigger warning at the beginning of the article is
this trigger warning.
And I never knew what that meant.
But that means that some girls have been so fucking traumatized or guys have
been so traumatized after being raped that they can't read about.
They can't read about it.
They'll have fucking flashbacks.
So you have to put this trigger warning on top.
And so to me it's like,
I dunno man,
if it comes down to,
and there were feminists that I went on TV with like feminist writers who are
like demonizes,
he's humorless,
cons who were fucking quoting Sarah Silverman,
the Wanda Sykes rate bit the Carlin rape bit.
You know,
there are definitely ways to do it.
Um,
but if there a girl in an audience,
even that girl who heckled,
if she was fucking raped and even if tosh is totally 100% kidding when she was,
it says,
when two people are going to get five guys rape you,
you know what I do think that that girl having a fucking flashback or any girl
in that audience having a fucking rape flashback,
I'm like,
it's not worth,
it's not worth the bid.
And there's so much stuff with rape that you can talk about that you can make
funny.
Um,
and I think that all topics and comedy should be addressed.
And I think the best comedians are the ones that can address those really edgy
topics.
But if it's going to be like a sloppily,
it would be funny if you were raped.
And there were almost definitely girls he's constructing.
No,
he's responding to someone saying something really stupid about rape that
completely limits the amount of subjects he can respond with.
Well,
and the has to respond with something that applies to rape,
but again,
I didn't with the military,
there are tons of other comics who have,
who have dealt with hecklers,
who have done it in other ways and you didn't because someone wanted to kick
your ass.
Someone ran up to the stage of wanting to kick your ass.
You realize you were in danger.
That's completely facetious to say that you didn't do it for no reason.
No,
but I mean I just say that this guy that his,
his idea with him saying,
don't you think it would be funny if five guys raped her?
Like,
no,
he's not supporting rape.
If you are that sensitive,
you do not belong in a comedy club.
If you,
if the word rape,
we'll send you into a fucking panic.
I feel unfortunate.
I feel sad for you.
You are very unfortunate that this has happened to you.
Maybe a comedy club is not the best place for you.
Maybe you should go somewhere else where it isn't a 100% uncensored ride through
the mind and imagination of Daniel Tosh and not to be interrupted by a moron.
And when that Moron does interrupt with something completely non-ironic
ridiculous,
insane.
He was,
he was saying that rape is bad of course.
But let's say that she was hypothetically tough shit.
And this is the one that she should shut her fucking mouth.
The comedy.
If you,
if you have been traumatized to a situation where you could be fucking enjoying
your night at the comedy club.
Right.
And I'm not saying this wasn't it,
we don't know who she is.
Let's say she was enjoying and at the colony club she was raped at a horrible
fucking fashion.
Not that there's like a pleasant area.
Unfortunate.
And if he was saying that just fucking comes out,
that's just an emotional response.
You remember like she needs to grow the fuck up.
And that's when when a,
when a guy says something like that to you and it's gross and everybody laughs
and it's ridiculous when you don't,
you go home and write a blog.
You don't need people supporting you because you're an idiot,
but that's why it happened.
That's Ptsd Shit.
I'm like,
you can't,
if somebody gets,
she didn't say in her blog that she was raped.
She said in her blog that she felt offended that he would joke around about ray.
No,
I was talking about you were saying Ptsd hypothetical.
Let's say that girl was like,
if that girl did right then in a blog would be a totally different blog by
warranting and justifying this more ronic opinion on,
you know,
someone having an ad lib to deal with a Heckler,
which what you're doing is you're supporting the idea that the,
the,
the positive idea behind not raping someone is more important than a show.
That's more important than jokes.
It's more important that you never bring up the idea that rape can be funny
cause that's then you're eliminating that,
that a gap as the opposite.
I said,
rape can ever be funny.
It can be funny for a Heckler,
but that's again,
that's the opposite of what I said right now of rape can ever be funny.
It can be funny when you know a,
someone is not being serious about it and to someone is talking about her rape
isn't funny.
That automatically makes it funny if they're a heckler.
If a heckler talks about rape not being funny ever,
and then the comic says,
wouldn't it be funny if somebody raped her?
You know,
he doesn't mean that his intent is not that a bunch of people should storm,
but that is the correct thing for him to say.
But again,
dealing with a nightclub comedian and people are drinking alcohol,
that would be fun.
But I wrote that tweet.
That was after you see my point at all.
Yes.
And what's the difference between Miss Rachel rape,
listening to this podcast on having a flashback right now?
You know,
we didn't give her any kind of rape warning before this podcast.
You all your,
you're tough on some crazy rate.
But I'm also not saying like,
Hey Rachel,
you specifically,
I hope you get raped.
But she also,
he didn't really mean that she should get raped.
What he was doing was being a standup comedian and a fucking club.
We're one person has to chime in there.
Dumb Shit here.
Here's what I wrote that the,
the tweet you,
when it first happened,
I w I essentially retweeted the article and said something like,
wow,
that was fucking shitty cause that's how I felt.
I didn't care that much about it.
I was like,
Eh,
it's another comic who is,
you know,
whatever.
When I started getting really upset and writing the angry or tweets and writing
more and more about it is when he listened to people who were reading the tweets
and you're like,
this is a good opportunity.
I am so matching now.
Rape is great,
but for AP wants to kick butt.
I just didn't understand why this was like our hill to die on.
Like comics don't have fucking health insurance.
Like comics have not really United around much.
And it was just so bizarre.
Like people can rally around fucking Dane Cook the next week for the Aurora
shooting.
You know what I mean?
Like when he made jokes about that,
like there was no big,
it was just that people were just so,
they just,
the tweets,
I was getting more crazy.
I mean I was watching these bloggers who have blogged about being rape
survivors,
re tweeting these people who like these amateur comics and people like that who
thought if they fucking tweeted some rape survivor,
fucking Dan would house should be friends with them or let them like open for
him.
They were tweeting like,
I hope you get raped and just like more fucking rape threats.
Right.
Will you introduce yourself into the argument again,
you introduced yourself and your opinion into the argument.
So you were judged.
You said that you feel you would rather be heckled,
then contribute to rape culture.
You introduced you oh yeah.
Until the argument.
So of course that of course you're going to get whiplash.
Of course you're going to get,
no,
I'm asking about me.
I'm saying that when you have these,
no,
I actually didn't get it that bad.
I mean this is the first time you said you did.
You were just telling us no,
no,
no.
I said bloggers,
feminist bloggers who have written about being rape survivors were getting raped
threats.
But you,
you got a lot of like Shitty tweets too.
I mean,
I got some,
I got some shitty tweets.
Yeah,
for sure.
But like that's what you're not shot.
It's not about,
no,
cause I,
I wouldn't no point was I trying to make this one,
the Jonah Goldberg name is one thing,
but this I wasn't trying to make about me.
I just want to Goldberg and that's the other guys to do.
Yeah.
I just wanted the people who follow me to know that like,
because most comics,
uh,
defended it.
And so I just wanted to,
I just wanted girls to know that I'm like,
you know,
if you've been through this,
like I don't,
I don't think that's funny.
I hope never funny,
real rape,
unless it's at the all starts to work.
It's just a,
it's just a piece of work.
I started writing about writing about ray environment of a standup comedy club
where he's being forced to live ad Lib.
But again,
when I,
we started talking about rape culture,
it wasn't specifically when I halfheartedly retweeted the Gawker article about
Taj,
it was about the responses that people started to get that were so violent and
not in a comedy club setting,
but just like personal fucking threats that a lot of the girl journalist and my
timeline we're re tweeting about just dude saying like,
so they would say something critical Taj [inaudible] and they would say we
usually get fucking raped.
Right.
And it was just that say something critical about toss wouldn't journalists
like,
so like what were they saying that just like wrote a piece about it and like
would contrast like with Tosh said to like the Wanda Sykes rape joke of the
Carlin rape joke and like they analyzed it because that's your job,
fucking dumb.
They have to be to actually analyze that.
The whole thing is so simple.
But I'm like that,
that's what they do.
Their media critics,
they,
uh,
he,
they analyze like that's just what they do.
They write about popular and a lot of times they do it because that was their
job and they need something to talk about is the risk of staff might not
necessarily be logical,
but the response isn't necessarily be like,
I'm going to tell that person.
I hope they get raped.
You know what I mean?
Like that's just one of those things where it's just like,
I have written stuff that's Sony people disagree with.
I've never gotten raped.
Threats,
you've probably never gotten buckle up.
Uh,
you're going to get some desk squad seven today.
You live in,
look,
check your Twitter.
Since we've been on this podcast,
it's common sun.
It's just in one big letter just says rape,
rape,
40 characters.
But uh,
but yeah,
man,
I'm like,
I just don't think we know what that's like where it's like journalists,
they don't know what it's like trying to get through a fucking show on Friday
night and some dummy has to yell out something stupid.
It doesn't make sense.
Right.
Again,
I'm like,
you can deal with that.
But it's no,
you're not
dealt with it.
And in my opinion,
he dealt with it the right way.
And that's not being pro rape,
just being words.
These are words,
there's you're not,
it's not actions and it's not in supportive rape in any way,
shape or fashion.
It's a joke.
And if you can't realize he's joking,
you are unfit to listen to other human beings taught.
No ma'am.
If you're influenced by that,
if you're influenced by Daniel tosh thing,
would it be funny if she got raped by five people?
If you were influenced by that,
you are clearly mentally incapable of communicating with people.
Man.
It should be removed from the side.
Both me and you have heard jokes that were like,
that sucks.
That wasn't a bad joke dude.
Right?
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying everyone is subjective and if you've been through a certain thing in
your life,
if you've been threatened with rape or if you had been raped or have you been
assault or if you live in a culture where a lot of fucking girls were raped,
that you know you have to think about walking home by yourself and shit like
that.
Maybe that Shit's not as funny to you and that's okay.
Just like it's okay for him to,
to,
to say what he wants to say.
It's okay for that girl to get offended.
It's okay for me not to think it's fucking funny.
It's okay for you to think it was the right thing to say.
Like all of this stuff is fine.
I'm just saying that if I were given the choice,
not in this tough situation because everything I wrote and dude,
you criticized it and said that you sometimes are embarrassed of your gender.
Of course I am.
When you have,
when you,
when you have girls that are afraid to go to the fucking park because they're
going to get raped.
Yeah,
guys can be fucking creepy.
Right.
But that's when you have skewed hold on.
Stop.
First of all,
if you say that one in six,
does that mean one in six men?
Rape is,
that doesn't mean that as well because if that's the case,
I was embarrassed about that part of humanity but not my fucking gender.
That's ridiculous.
A comic you've used like hyperbole.
It's fucking Twitter.
Exactly what this is.
Why him saying that someone being raped by five people being funny should also,
what did he say?
Seven seven she wouldn't know.
You said five touch the,
I was waiting for you to be like,
oh you had an insert that 70 fucking shoe with a waterfall.
There is new things,
so seven there is part of me hoping that you would be like seven.
Oh He's a child with a child.
I was semi praying for him to say 17 you'd be like seven now that's you saying
that.
Did you know that I should be able to recognize her verbally.
Why don't you recognize it with tosh thing?
You should be read by five do cause I'm a fucking comedian.
Right.
Then why you ever
supporting him?
Because I wreck.
I recognize that me personally,
just like you recognize it,
just like I recognize that religion is silly.
You do your thing,
you're protecting the world from idiots being influenced by not protecting the
world.
I'm voicing my opinion that if I had the choice between there's a fucking rape
survivor there who could get a triggered flashback or like,
you know,
talk about rape in a different way.
Because again,
like I don't think it's fucking funny.
I've already burned the comedy bridges.
You might as well go all the way with it.
I don't think it's funny to personally,
I think it's easy and I think it's a cop out to joke about people who are
already shit on to me,
I don't think it's edgy.
I don't think you can
paraphrase fucking prior rape,
rape,
rape survivors.
Well,
okay,
but you're saying rape survivor when he made a rape joke.
She's not a rape survivor man.
No,
I'm saying in the audience,
but she is the victim.
She's the person who got said that word audience right now of this podcast
though.
There's tons of fucking people probably sitting around shaking.
Yeah.
You don't have a problem with that.
This is a bullshit argument really.
It,
we're actually like talking about the issue because it's an issue that's
important to be talked about.
Again,
I didn't read anyone and I certainly wasn't saying anyone you can't talk about,
right.
Yeah.
Don't murder is horrible.
Robbery is horrible.
Armed robbery,
car robbery,
uh,
everything is horrible.
It doesn't mean just because it exists.
You can never talk about out of fear when someone,
someone in the audience may not have a caring when someone gets fucking
murdered,
you're not like,
well,
what was she?
What was he wearing like before he got murdered?
Like rape is the one is listened to your,
that's bullshit.
Because if somebody gets murdered,
someone can say,
you shouldn't been in there.
He should have been the neighborhood.
And what if the person who knows the person who's been murdered,
who had to work in a bad place to support their family?
Here's you say that it's the same fucking subject when you're joking around on
stage,
especially in a situation where touched it,
where it's a complete ad Lib for you to analyze it in that way and come up with
he's contributing to rape culture is proposed.
I,
I still,
I still stand by it because I just don't give a shit again and comparison.
And this isn't a heckler issue for me anymore.
Like I don't like people who hack all right.
I hate it.
And I don't think that Daniel tosh wanted that girl to get raped.
Right.
But I just don't give a shit about comedy enough that if I'm onstage and I say
something that could cause someone in the audience or multiple people in the
audience because I'm not doing it in a way that's attacking,
I dunno,
like a higher,
like no one's sitting around and being like,
you know,
he's had it too good for too long a rape victims.
Like I wish someone would fucking talk about them.
Like I just think there are smarter ways to fucking do it and I'm not a fan of
it.
Yeah.
And if I have it,
what if he said,
oh,
I would have,
I would hope the chimps would eat your face.
Is that okay?
Well,
because we don't have a history.
Is that a man getting,
but there's one in six girls haven't had their facing.
What if that woman in the audience was in the audience who've got her face eaten
up by a chimp and everybody laughed.
Hahahaha would be
so funny.
Tragical she got her face writ bitten up by where women are afraid to go to the
police to report a fucking chimp incident cause they're gonna be like,
well,
did you use to fuck the chimp drinking when you were getting together with the
chimp?
And that is to me,
when I say culture,
I'm not talking about Daniel Tosh.
I'm not talking about a comic who talks about rape.
I'm saying that it was just so fucking bizarre to me that with all of the Shit,
uh,
the comics have not gathered around that.
It was like the rape joke.
Like I just like an Austin come with,
they gathered around,
I don't know,
man.
I gathered around someone protesting him,
shutting down a heckler and saying that rape is completely off subject.
But no,
no.
I went on a fucking liberal
by,
hold on,
wait,
I went on a liberal.
That's why it happened.
That's why the whole thing happened.
They brought on as some moron,
right?
Hecklers are morons right now.
She's like,
again,
get heckled a heckler that didn't even understand what he was saying.
Sure.
But again,
if I were raped,
maybe I would act quickly and hastily,
uh,
about a subject that's affected my life so much and such a tragic way.
And again,
that's what makes us happy.
If I was,
she didn't write that in our blog and that's what everybody responded,
just became an issue because she wrote this blog,
right.
That's why it became an issue,
sending the blog off to these websites.
It was her fucking personal blog.
Yeah.
But if you fucking be clean viral,
and that's why it became an issue that you talked.
Sure.
But again,
like you keep saying that like,
I don't think rape should ever be mentioned.
Like the feminist saying that you think rape can be funny.
Right.
You think that one is licensing it and make it funny?
100% okay.
Why didn't Tosh make it funny there?
It sounded funny to me because it was used in the same way that rape is used in
the sense just to shut someone up.
It was you.
It was rape is not used to shut the up.
That's a crazy way to shut people up.
It's a pouch.
Shut up.
I'm going to rape.
You know?
But it's no,
but I mean,
it's psychologically been proved that it's not about being a coach.
It's not,
it's not about being a horny.
It's a crime.
It's a psychological crime.
That's a crazy comparison and I don't buy that either.
It's about both.
If it was just about controlling someone,
they would hold you down.
They fuck you because it's power and sexual at the same time.
I don't think we'll have some creepy thing when it comes to physically
empowering,
being physically overpowering a person and and and fucking them and had ax with
them.
My whole thing is like,
I'm a comic.
I've been heckled.
I know what it's like to be heckled.
I'm not a female.
I haven't been raped.
I don't know what it's like and if it comes down to a fucking dude who was not
censored,
who still has his number one show on comedy central,
who still plays at the club?
No one.
Oh look.
A lot of people wanted them censored.
A lot of people wanted him fire.
The cared for him to get fired.
I didn't call.
I just call fucking station.
I it because it's not my fucking job.
You said support a comic.
Just because I happened
to be a comedian when I don't,
but you said he's contributing to rape culture.
I think that whole situation,
100% I think what we're doing,
I think right now making,
putting the onus on women that they're uptight bitches.
Do you know what a slippery slope the says that you are.
You are literally condoning censorship.
You're saying that people's words can affect actions.
So you're saying someone completely joking around about rape,
Ken support.
Rape.
It is ridiculous.
It is dickless statement but that's not it.
That's what you're saying.
That is what you're saying.
Listen man,
if you say that he's contributing the rape culture by saying that with his
mouth,
by joking around in a way that absolutely,
well no,
he wasn't serious.
Five guys,
five guys just going to jump out and raid better.
But again,
that would be funny.
That's not what he's saying.
He's making a joke.
And you're saying that contributes to rape culture.
So what you're saying is his words should be censored because they contribute to
bullshit.
You're saying they contribute to racial shit cause I never said take him off the
air.
I never said so he has to sell.
You're still saying he contributes to rape?
No,
I didn't say a contributor as in rape culture.
Right,
because what fucking,
what does that mean?
If he's not contributing to rate?
You go on fucking Twitter during those days and all of his fans started
threatening girls with rape.
That's fucking rape culture.
Rape Culture is women being in constant fucking fear because dudes are fucking
threatening them because dudes are writing and say,
well,
I see you where you fucking live,
I'm going to rape you.
That is rape culture,
right?
Culture Dude,
that's idiots.
This idea that he is somehow or another contributing to that by even mentioning
the word rape,
you can't stop someone from being a fucking idiot and by not saying a joke about
a subject doesn't keep other morons from using that subject whenever they freely
want,
right?
It's just,
it comes up at any time they're allowed to have their reactions and start
saying,
oh,
I'm gonna to a group.
You Bitch,
that doesn't mean you should never talk about rape.
And so for you to say that in that moment,
he shouldn't bring it up cause he's contributing to a bunch of fucking apes
yelling rape at women on Twitter or Facebook or whatever.
They're completely unrelated,
completely unrelated and not have done it.
If there wasn't so much fucking know those dudes would not have done.
If there wasn't a fucking blog written by some one woman who all of a sudden
everybody and you had to comment on,
then it becomes a part of the national discourse.
Same Shit.
We're fucking fault.
Like if that kick it is,
well,
it's true.
It is her fault.
She should have shut her fucking mouth one and she should not run a dumb blog
about it.
I don't know,
man diarrhea of the mouth blog about it where she didn't take any personal
accountability for interrupting a show with a fucking rabid standup comedian in
mid stride,
in his fucking prime,
on stage in Hollywood on a Friday night or Saturday night,
whatever the fuck it was.
I Dunno,
Dude.
This is what it is.
Okay,
she's interrupting the show.
You're caught in the crossfire.
You took a hit.
It wasn't real dummy.
If he said he hopes a unicorn comes down and drowns you with his pice,
is that real?
Come on.
It's,
we're not talking reality here.
We're talking jokes one and he's not contributing through has been drawn by a
Unicorn,
Unicorn pissed,
Yada Chrome has,
I'm sorry,
I,
it's,
it's nonsense.
It's nonsense.
And how many of these people that unreported,
like the Wah Wah,
one out of seven or whatever,
people didn't report it because they had orgasms.
There could be some kind of weird fucking number like that in there that just
totally voids the whole number anyway.
Okay,
well that might not be it.
I'm going to see all that that hey
Jamie,
you,
you know,
I think if anything makes people say stupid shit,
like I hope you get raped.
It's when people stand up for someone who says something like rape should never
be talked about but,
or like rape should have been discussed.
But like we,
you're talking about Roy,
a rape culture.
So whenever you step in and say,
I support this over rape culture,
there's a bunch of idiots who you are,
you're introducing yourself into the sea of humanity and you're shocked when
some people bounce back at,
you know,
but shot because that's what you're doing.
You're introducing,
your idea's going to have one.
I'm like one of like five comedians who said something that we're the reason
that these girls started getting rape threats.
Like that's crazy.
That's not what I'm saying at all.
I'm saying that you said that Daniel tosh contributes to rape culture and I'm
telling the whole situation.
I thought that's true.
What did you mean?
What did you entering the discourse that actually contributed to by people
distribute it to people who think,
who people who get annoyed at like lefty vegans and they want to go,
you fucking queer hope you get rid of,
but that was fat.
You're right,
you're right.
Shit.
Anyway,
but they those people,
isn't that your rape culture though?
They weren't saying that to me.
They were saying that the fire,
I'm sure check your timeline now they are and I'm sure they said it then
anybody.
I sure a certain amount of people who read what you said had some sort of a
negative response to you.
There's no denying that.
Right?
Luckily a lot of your people who are mad at me,
I just checked my Twitter.
They're not putting a period before my name,
so it's only,
it's only going to me.
It's like kills.
Hey everyone,
uh,
pure idiot.
Oh,
they have to put a period before you.
Otherwise it only goes,
yeah,
they,
I think they want to talk to you,
dude.
Oh,
that sounds kind of funny.
Jamie Kelsey and beat me up in a kickboxing match and them rape me and then
Hashtag the rape culture.
But do you feel me on this man?
Do you know what I'm trying,
I'm trying to put some sense in your head because you're being silly and you're
opening yourself up to unwarranted and unnecessary criticism can be avoided.
It can all be avoided by being a little bit harder on yourself.
Man.
I don't know.
Not,
not introducing yourself into these,
these things.
I mean,
and this all,
your people already think,
uh,
I miss on my people.
I'm not running a cult.
No,
no,
no.
I don't have.
Yeah,
they're there by a town and go to Portland.
I had way too many,
uh,
forgettable starting Colton,
Portland.
That's the place that here you got way too many white.
I have way too many people who were raped who tweeted me and was like,
ah,
you got a cop.
They'll be happy.
If you talk about fucking water socking,
you talk about a certain amount of things is that we're going to be a giant
group of people that support you.
It doesn't mean that you're right.
I mean,
we're going to disagree on this,
right?
For sure.
Disagree on this.
Every fucking committee in the world disagrees with you,
but I'm like,
I don't care.
You know what that is though as a common comment that you understand what's
going on.
It's not the comedy means much to you.
It's in human interaction,
man.
It's when you're at a movie and some guy's on his fucking phone talking,
shut up,
bitch.
You're fucking up the show.
It's real simple,
right?
That's what tosh did is stop what was fucking up the show.
It had nothing to do with rape or contributing to rape culture.
Like when something like what you just said happens,
like people don't galvanize around that.
You know what I mean?
They shouldn't,
they should galvanize around putting a picture of her and say,
see this bitch.
She doesn't understand humor.
She can't take a joke.
So she'd be a photo of her with a red line across her face until you can come in
and explain to us that you're sorry that you didn't understand how he was joking
around about it and nothing can be funny about rape and you just blurted it out
because you're a self righteous dummy who thinks that you should be able to
espouse your politically correct opinions at any fucking time.
They're warranted in your silly little fucking dumb mine and cute,
including hijacking a fucking commy club.
You're not capable of handling a comedy club.
You shouldn't be there.
Just like if your ears hurt when things are loud,
you shouldn't go to a fucking rock club.
If you,
you're scared of violence.
You shouldn't sit front row at a UFC fight.
It's all the same.
It's not like we should nerf the world to make it safe for everybody.
If you don't enjoy someone talking about controversial Shit,
you certainly shouldn't go to an adult nightclub that's doing standup comedy.
Or a guy like Daniel fucking tosh who has one of the most edgy shows on TV
period is doing a standup and he makes a joke because you hackle and that joke
happens you about what you heckled a bout.
You can't feel like you're a victim because you're not a victim.
You're a dummy who doesn't belong in a comedy club,
right?
Well,
again,
I am not defending the hailing Rosie to my ears hurt.
You're stupid.
If your ears are sensitive,
you don't stand next to the fucking speaker.
If you don't like watching,
dudes gets their ass kicked.
Don't,
don't go to a UFC fight if you don't like black people.
Don't watch basketball.
It's really simple.
And when you introduce yourself,
if you introduce yourself into the equation like that woman did,
you got to take the hit,
but there's going to take the hit.
But again,
like you thought it was,
you know,
and we were talking about how good it is when people stand up and protest.
He's fucking politicians is that you disagree with this?
So of course,
and again,
I disagree with that.
Agree with standup comedy.
Show that he wouldn't someone dictating policy or changing the way people live
their lives.
It's someone who's cracking jokes on stage trying to make people laugh again,
someone who interrupts that process because they're done.
I hate that you're agreeing racy for supporting your fucked up.
You should have wrote something a lot more detailed.
Then you should explain yourself and 40
characters.
We should do it on Twitter.
You should link to a blog because this is something that can cover people.
Short attention span.
No,
I get mad at people who write dumb blogs.
I love well-written on his blog.
When I get mad at dumpy,
my heckle,
I fucking write about blog about high.
They're shocked that someone could joke around about that.
By the way,
I heard the joke killed.
I heard most of the audience laughed really hard.
I thought it was hilarious because you know why it was.
That's because,
because it was Joe Tex.
Check this out there.
Somebody told me to play this joy reed.
All right.
What is it?
Well,
I would say backing up completely,
I would,
I would like to argue the point that that wasn't even a joke.
He was making a statement.
Oh,
so you're the comedy club,
you're making a statement.
Um,
it's fair game for an audience member at ago.
I disagree with your statement because there's been various reports.
I'll look what happened and what happened.
And there's the [inaudible] statement and I find this very interesting,
especially when talking about it from a comics lens and he said that Daniel Tosh
on stage and said,
what would you guys like to talk about now that opens up a conversation with
your audience and somebody yelled rape and I don't know if it was this woman or
someone else said,
no,
rape jokes are never funny.
And then all of a sudden,
boom,
if that happened,
then yeah,
you ask the audience what they thought and people said some.
Yeah.
Okay.
Pause that.
Pause right there.
Because first of all,
she's not,
she's not telling the truth because she's omitting a very important part of why
he said that to her.
And she's doing that to make our point make more sense.
She omitted the fact that he was saying,
Oh yeah,
rape is real funny.
Like what's funny about rate?
Is it the humiliation that was the,
is it the violence?
It's stop.
Hold on.
Is this story's Winstead?
No,
no,
no.
Well then don't talk then.
Don't talk about it if you don't know the full story.
So Lizz Winstead interjected in or rather edited through the actual reality of
the conversation and cut out the part where he was detailing what is not funny
about rape,
to make it seem like what he did was more insensitive.
If she said,
I guarantee you if someone said rape,
and then,
you know,
he said,
uh,
you know,
a woman it actually rape was never funny.
And he said,
well,
wouldn't it be funny if five guys raped right now?
Guess what?
That's still funny.
You know why?
Because he's not being serious.
Okay.
If she's self righteously yelling out,
actually rape us.
Never funny.
It's right for him again to say,
wouldn't it be funny if she got raped by five people?
Okay,
he's joking.
He's not being fucking serious.
Just like when you see a guy in a movie and he's shooting at aliens,
he's not really in an alien war.
Okay.
It's fucking entertainment.
And which she did by omitting that very particular part is make it more heinous.
And yet I still agree with him and I disagree with her and her saying that it's
not a joke is ridiculous.
And I have a Lizz Winstead story from when I was an open that I'd like to share
with you.
This is where it gets really interesting.
When I was an open miker and I was not that good,
a comedian,
I was fucking two or three times on stage and Lizz Winstead already had been on
HBO.
She there and she was hosting an open mic night and I'm not trying to hold her
to the fire for this.
Okay.
But this is something that happened.
It happened more than 20 years ago.
She's on stage.
She had a friend,
Janine to Tulio was a very funny comic from Boston and they're all palling
around backstage or this whole girls club.
And um,
they were there having a great time.
And she said she got on stage and she,
she said,
I'm hosting open Mike night and when I'm here hosting,
hosting open Mike Night,
I've got rules,
here's the rules.
Okay,
no jokes about this.
No jokes about that.
No jokes about tits.
No,
no sexism.
She says no sexism.
She says no gay jokes.
She has a list she's reading and she decides that she's going to interrupt the
standup comedians while they're on stage and stop them from performing their
jokes and interrupt them because she decides that a joke is racist.
She decided a joke,
a sexist.
So there's a door next to this stage.
So the comedians are onstage and she's getting on stage and interrupting
individual performance.
Stop,
stop,
stop that sexist.
So he,
this guy,
Brian,
I forget his fucking name,
he was a very funny guy,
but he was particularly shy and he was an open mic or a career open miker he was
a guy that had been doing,
are you into what a bitch,
any attention.
He was a guy who would struggle to keep it together on stage every time.
And he was a very gifted comic writer.
But he very uncomfortable performer.
He had a really hard time performing.
So he goes on stage and he has this joke where he says,
um,
something about,
I always make sure I open up the car door for my hooker and Liz Winstead
interrupts,
stop,
stop sexism.
And he says,
and don't think he doesn't appreciate it,
which is his punchline.
Okay.
So she's standing on stage right after he says that,
and she stopped him and he's so awkward.
He's got his eyes close during his,
his fucking thing.
I mean,
it's,
it's just,
it's so fucking annoying one that's driving me crazy.
So I get on stage,
okay.
And I'm in the middle of something and she comes out and says,
sexism,
stop,
stop.
And I said,
Liz,
don't you get enough fucking attention?
I go,
you go on stage every night you have this HBO special,
you're a national headliner.
And yet you can't let us an open miker have five minutes to try to say whatever
the fuck they want to say.
You have to come on and interrupt.
And so she says to me,
you know,
I know the people who own this club,
I'll just let you know right now.
This is not right.
This is 100% real.
And I said,
that's it really.
I called,
that's what you're telling me.
You're a professional fucking comedian.
And I have a very good point about you needing attention to interrupting sets.
And you tell me that you know the people who booked this club insinuating that
you can stop me from working here.
I go,
fucking really?
I'm done.
And so I walked off the stage,
I put the microphone down and I walked off the stage and I'll never forget that.
And so listening to that,
Laney,
just understand and,
and judge that because that's a true thing that happened to eight.
Oh,
of course it does.
But that's a true thing that happened to a open mic comic by a professional
headline or comedian.
Sure.
And this is the point where it's sexism can bounce the other way and it becomes
nonsense.
It becomes you and forcing your ideology on other people and you,
it's not about being fair.
And right and running,
adjust happy society where people around allowed creative differences.
No,
it's about you and forcing your own ego and bullshit on other people.
Yeah,
I didn't mean it was one of those things where like
let's listen to the rest of what she has to say.
A woman's report and then the club owner issued a statement and I find this very
interesting,
especially when talking about it from a comics lens and he said that Dale task
on stage and said,
what would you guys like to talk about now that opens up a conversation with
your audience.
We already said something so it's not,
it's not quite in the same thing as being heckled,
being heckled for a joke you told.
Yeah,
there was a joke.
It wasn't even like the equivalent of if there was one tiny room and he had
said,
you know,
wouldn't it be funny if everybody just lynched that guy right now because a joke
as it is an attack on that person because he was obviously angry with it.
Hold on,
you got stupid.
That is because that's ridiculous because it's not,
when she was the only woman in a room full of men.
That's so dumb.
We don't fuck.
People are so stupid with their analogies.
What?
That would be the same as was there was one black guy and everybody's like,
let's go get them hold up.
Fuck.
Is that the same?
How the fuck is that the same?
Why is everybody so God damn crazy and why does so many people want to cry
victim when they're just stew bed?
This is not a victim issue.
This is us stupid person issue.
I mean I think it comes down to she does agree with him.
We disagree on how she handled it.
I disagree with you.
You disagree with me,
but it's like what do you disagree with me?
Oh,
just about the whole rape thing.
The thing you've been yelling at me about for what?
I disagree with what you you mean you've never disagreed?
Well,
the fact that I'm not honestly never have because I've,
I've told you that I don't think that he contributes to raping people.
And you're saying that you didn't say that?
I do not think he contributors to raping people.
You're saying that contributes to rape culture and I'm saying what the fuck is
that then?
Well,
and that's what I was telling you.
It's the fact that we live in a culture where women who have been raped aren't
allowed to.
The way we're saying it,
go to comedy clubs because they might get offended.
And I'm saying that I think that that sort of sucks for them considering they
were fucking money man.
And then now they have to watch where they go.
That's when like that was,
you're going to have to take away every single thing that people have been
victimized from it and take it out of the vocabulary,
the vernacular of comedy then,
because then everything like I've been beat up before.
If you've been beat up,
you have a gun that's way worse than getting it right.
John Brian's been robbed a gun and he was fucking freaking out every time he was
in a parking lot for months afterwards.
And I know that's true,
but you know what?
He still go to a comedy club and know about the time where he almost lost his
life with a gun in his fucking face.
And if someone jokes about robbery,
he should be able to laugh at that.
I would take rape af over getting,
getting that happened to me again unless someone,
wow.
Wow.
I would,
I would get raped before getting robbed by gun again.
Which really?
You say that,
but I don't think there's nothing.
I see what your point is.
I see your point is like someone just wants to have sex and I'm going to kill
you.
Right?
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
We're murders worse than rape.
Yeah,
you're right.
Absolutely.
If your loved ones,
you know got raped,
you'd feel horrible.
If they've got murdered,
your feel worse.
But I don't know.
Either way you get murdered,
your owl,
come on,
it's terrible.
But you still can have loved ones and still have good experiences and yeah,
you're going to have bad memories.
But like I said,
it's not about us and like,
oh,
you know,
our wife was murdered or art wipe was raped.
It's about like the victim of the crime.
And like with rape,
you have to live with that shit forever.
I mean,
that is such a violent fucking act that people use that you saying that rape is
worse than murder.
It's so fucking crazy because rape is horrible for the person that gets raped.
Murder is horrible for the person who dies and everyone loves them too,
who will never see them again because they don't exist because someone stopped
their fucking life.
That's worse.
They're both terrible.
But to say that one rape is worse because you remember it,
it's crazy because there's therapy.
People get on ecstasy.
They do Mtma and have these uh,
posttraumatic stress disorder clinics where they work with people with
psychedelic drugs and help them recover from things by having spiritual
experiences that you can recover from rape.
It's a terrible,
terrible thing.
I am not condoning it or endorsing it in any way,
shape or form.
I think murders words.
Brian almost got murdered and my girlfriend,
16 year old who was raped,
has access to psychedelic dry.
You're right.
Look,
I'm not saying that rape is good.
It's terrible.
That's a terrible thing,
but murderous.
Worst man.
And you could joke about murder all day.
You could joke about murdering people all day and no one in the audience who's
lost a friend to murder should be allowed to step in and go,
I've lost a friend of murderer.
Stop it with your murder jokes,
right?
Yeah,
but I don't know if you would like,
again,
like lash out and attack that person as much.
Like if that person was fucking,
you would,
if they heckled,
you would.
If you were telling a joke about murder,
someone said,
talk about murder and you go north.
It's funny about murder.
You know what's funny about murder?
The bullet killing someone though an Arrow,
a machete,
and some of those actually murders never funny and you go,
wouldn't it be funny if somebody just murdered him?
But again,
man,
where would you stand on this and not,
this is what you stand on.
This jury.
Would you stand in that if somebody wrote a blog and the blog was written by a
fat man,
I served dumb man that you don't want,
you don't want is love and he believes in the confederate flag.
And what if he wrote a blog about that?
Would you stand up for him?
Cause it's the same fucking issue.
It is the same issue.
It's certainly it because murder is getting fucking reported.
There's not a stigma,
uh,
about murder.
The murder or the person that the family of the family of the person who was
murdered doesn't have to defend the fucking victim.
The victim isn't fucking put on trial sometimes they're obviously they listen
man,
the euro,
you are creating a lot of strong in here.
This is not w murder is worse.
And you're saying that [inaudible] happened and it was a murder joke that that
would be okay.
That's what you're saying is that I say that's crazy.
Here's what I'm saying cause I think we were talking to
no because we're talking about comedy man.
We're not talking about reality.
That's my point.
I know that if someone says,
would it be funny if somebody just murdered him?
You know that that's worse than saying,
would it be funny if someone just raped him?
That's not worse.
It is worse.
Murders.
Murders were way worse than murder is worse than rape.
Man,
I don't,
I don't think we have this conversation.
You'd rather be murdered and raped.
What's that?
You would rather be murdered and raped,
then raped.
Yes.
You would rather be murdered and raped.
I would rather,
if someone is going to have to live with rape or rape,
none of us will have to understand saying murders,
none of us understand what these fucking girls are going.
Well,
you're not,
I'm not talking about that man.
I'm talking about his murder worsen.
Raped by say it is for me.
Yes.
Yeah,
of course.
I would rather get,
I would rather for every other fucking human being that's ever lived,
murders worse than me.
Don't fucking know what they're going through.
We don't.
And the fact,
Jamie,
you're talking nonsense.
The key to bringing up the feeling
of the show was all about how,
you know we have to have more empathy for each other,
but were screaming about how fucking rape victims
and not go to a fucking comedy.
We're comparing murder to rape.
That's what we're doing.
We're not doing all these other things.
You're trying to introduce into the,
we're not doing that.
We're comparing motor,
the rape,
and we're saying that murder,
it's worse than rape.
You kill people.
They cease to exist.
They die.
If someone has sex with you against your will,
it's a horrible,
horrible thing that should hurt you.
It's going to be a bad thing,
but it's not as bad as murder picked.
The reason that it's more stigmatized,
the reason that more people will realize more than murder,
man,
if you found out that a guy raped someone,
you,
oh,
what an asshole.
If you find a guy murdered someone,
that's a different fucking feeling.
I see.
That's right.
He's a great,
I want the guy who murdered people.
I want the guy who murdered people killed immediately removed from society.
I want the guy who raped someone.
I want to find out what the fuck went wrong,
that he de-humanize people to the point where his sexual needs or power needs or
whatever the fuck did that supersedes his need to come to,
to compliment his fellow humans toe to be a part of humanity and culture.
What went wrong with this guy?
I want to find out if he was raped by his Pamet parents.
We can learn something about that guy,
but we can't.
We can't with murder.
I think a lot of times with murder,
it's just people have access to things and they have impulses and they do
terrible things.
I mean,
there's a lot of different reasons for murder.
This is a million different reasons for murder.
There's only a couple of different reasons for rape.
It's not,
it's not nearly as complicated.
There's all sorts of reasons why people want people dead.
There's not reasons why people want to rate people.
There's only a couple.
It's either you want some sex,
so you want to control,
so going to be violent with them.
It's not like it's fucking bitch looked in my bike.
Funny.
I got a raper.
You know,
this is it's people kill people.
They were the wrong clothes.
You know,
you can wear blue and a red neighborhood and they kill you.
There's a lot more differences.
Why people murder you then rape you.
So it's an unfair comparison but murders worse,
you know,
and I,
yeah,
you can't understand what it's like for someone to have been victimized by that
crime.
You also can understand when it's worse for a mother to lose her son to violence
because that could be just as bad or worse.
And I think like talking to these hypothetical,
it's like,
yeah,
but that's what you keep doing.
Keep bringing up to hypothetical justifications.
And I'm saying that you can't do that man.
And I'm saying,
you know that they're both just jokes that a guide joking around,
but I wouldn't be funny if that guy got murdered is the same as someone saying,
wouldn't it be funny if that guy got raped?
These doesn't really mean that he's making a joke to move a comedy show along.
So we're all introducing it and Lizz Winstead fucking hypocrite.
Bullshit to her to say on stage that it's not even a joke.
Of course.
Had to JOE's out there.
It's a direct job.
There's the joke ready set up.
Actually rape is never funny.
Punchline.
Wouldn't it be funny if she just got raped by five guys?
That's,
that's it.
That's a joke.
She to say that that's not a joke is silly.
It's not saying we're endorsing rape.
It's not saying people should,
should be allowed to say horrible things to people.
It's you're not dealing with the context of the situation where someone was
reacting to someone's saying something dumb.
Am I rape that bathroom in a bit?
Are you going to,
Can I pee first?
Sure.
Do you have to go?
I've got to pay a,
yeah.
Why?
I was supposed to go like half an hour ago.
Listen man,
I,
I didn't want to hold you to the coals like this,
but this is a,
this is a very controversial,
we legit,
we legitimately disagree.
I don't think you are pro rape.
I fucking still hope you don't think I'm pro censorship.
Do you want?
If you think you should have done that,
then you think that he could not have been fun even though everybody laughed.
Yeah.
But I mean that's like everybody's sense of humor is fucking subjective.
Like you don't think everything can be so took for those people.
That was a great moment.
So why?
So why,
so why do you think that didn't happen with when cook the next week or two weeks
later or whatever there were again,
because murder is worse than rape.
There you go man.
People got like no one really defended that.
But don't nobody defended cook because it wasn't a good joke.
But don't you think that it was joking around about the rape and or excuse me
about murder and it wasn't a good joke so nobody defended them.
That's why everybody defended tosh cause it cause murders worse than rape.
You son of a bitch.
I think people got mad at uh,
I know I got mad at the Ymca because the joke was that the movie was so bad.
He was thinking that.
What was it?
He want to hurt.
The movie's awesome.
It's fucking incredible.
That was the,
I got more mad at that than the murder thing where I was like,
well,
I know Dane Dane is a type of dude who will say things to try to be funny.
You know,
he's trying to,
he's trying to be edgy.
He's trying to crack a good joke,
but look,
man,
this is a crazy thing to do.
Do it a week later.
Should I fuck it?
Let's do it.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
he doesn't mean here's an easier,
uh,
and then I,
but this went well.
Um,
I don't again want to be censored.
I don't like calculators,
but
um,
me personally,
I don't like rape.
I don't like white on white violence either.
I don't like,
I don't like anything cunty but that also means when someone who was on non
rapist and nonviolent,
like Daniel Tosh is at a comedy club and he makes a joke about rape.
He shouldn't be fucking chastised by these dummies on the air.
This nonsense that you're hearing between,
from Lizz Winstead it's just so silly.
It's silly.
You shouldn't rate people apps a fucking lutely.
You also should shut your fucking mouth at a comedy club.
Don't want,
if you don't want to get blowback,
can we agree that we're all anti rape?
We're all anti rape,
but I do,
I guess I paid money for it,
but I do a,
you know,
I do go back to what you said before where it's just like,
I dunno,
as tedious as it may be or whatever.
I would much rather,
I just,
I dunno.
I think like me personally,
like when I write like I do think about it,
I'm like,
am I going after the right person?
Do you know what I mean?
And that was an ad Lib thing.
Like I'm taking it out of the tosh.
It's really simple,
man.
When you could have really said was great.
I mean,
this is what I said when I would say,
you should think what I think,
but what I,
my,
my point of view was that,
yeah,
you brave isn't funny.
But that was funny because he didn't rape anybody.
It's not a rape,
it's a word.
Words came out of his mouth.
It's describing a ridiculous fictional scenario.
I mean,
would it be worse if he said,
wouldn't it be funny if gargoyles came down and ate her asshole and,
and killed her again?
I'm,
yeah,
that would be worth,
it would be worse than this gargoyle jokes.
You're not giving yourself credit.
They're very funny.
Dolphin Piss,
drowning by dolphin pitches where the worst ways to go that is Unicorn is even
worse.
That's worse than rape for Unicorn.
But look what I'm saying is that this is comedy and it's not real.
And that's what a guy's doing when he's doing what Taj did is asking the
audience what I'm used to coming up with new material and he's fucking around.
But what I'm saying is like,
we all have comics,
we don't like me and you agree on it felt like tosh sheriff was funny.
I actually don't know much of it.
He's a good dude.
He's a good,
he's a good dude.
He's always friendly when every time I met him he's been real friendly to me of,
I only talked to Tosh a few times.
I did a show once Haber and have you did a thing with um,
we did a thing with Manny Pacquiao.
He was also a great guy.
Manny Pacquiao was like one of the nicest guys of all time.
You meet him,
you would never believe he's a stone cold killer.
He's so friendly and generous and nice to people.
Very small.
God.
Yeah.
And Daniel talks is very tall too,
but Tinder was house is a really nice guy man.
And he's not a hurtful person.
He's just trying to make some people laugh and do his gig and he does it really
well and you know,
and this and hear this from like these silly people like Lizz Winstead saying,
first of all it wasn't a joke.
I'm glad I told that story about open mic days cause I never told that story
before and maybe she doesn't remember it and maybe she'll tell you.
Say it's not true.
It's fucking true.
I remember that shit to the end.
Cause I remember I had this girlfriend I was dating at the time.
Her name was Stephanie.
She was older than me.
One of the first times ever dated a chick.
He's telling me what to do,
but she locked the fuck.
So it was fun.
She was cool.
She was a nice,
nice person,
but she was older than me and you just like tell me what to do.
And then after I got off stage,
I walked off the stage and uh,
she said,
you can't do that.
She said,
if you want to be a comedian,
you have to be a community.
Can't just quit.
In the middle of doing comedy was like,
Damn Bitch,
you feisty.
She was telling me what to do,
our thoughts and I'll never forget that man,
because I remember thinking,
I don't want to deal with this kind of people.
I mean,
it's nonsense.
If someone would actually fucking do that.
I don't want to Ryan coin,
that was the guy's name.
I don't want to do with censorship either.
And it's like,
I mean,
the thing is,
is like,
but that isn't the issue of debate it before and it's not okay,
not it's you,
you telling me that I shouldn't have said something like that.
No.
I'm saying I really should have said something like,
man,
well that was by saying contributes to rape culture though.
You are saying it should be censored.
I found that shitty.
Just like you found my opinion.
Shitty.
I didn't find your opinion shitty.
I found your opinion a little self involved and I felt like there's a certain
thing that some people do when they get on Twitter where they say things because
they know that they're going to get a bunch of people agreeing with them and
then not necessarily making.
Certainly because that fucking worked out for me.
That was my goal.
Lefties,
your your people for sure.
Now that you write on a daily basis,
I see.
I do write things.
Fellow liberals,
you write things on Twitter,
fellow liberals.
I know who you're communicating with,
your communicating with people who already love you.
That's a year where you're saying things that you want,
people who already love you and you know how they feel about things like that.
When you start saying shit like it's supporting rape culture.
You know who you're talking.
I'm shitty at business,
but if you thought that I thought this was gonna work out,
this was going to be a lot of fucking fun to deal with on shows podcast.
Like I know who follows me on Twitter,
but I know he was more vocal.
I,
I knew that I was going to get shit for this.
I wasn't like ecstatic about it,
but that doesn't mean that the only reason I'm not going to defense something
that I believe in his cause I don't want to piss off my friends like not what
I'm saying.
I didn't say that at all.
What I said was it seemed like you were preaching to the choir in a way that you
thought they wanted you to hear.
I never thought it was that.
No Dude.
So many thousands of people just knew we were ready for a fight and you said
like,
I have to stand my ground.
I fucking felt just like everybody will tweet their fucking opinions on how they
feel.
Just like you'll tweet your opinions on the wan drugs,
on the military,
industrial complex,
whatever.
It's you tweeting your opinions.
That was me tweeting my opinions that this opinion do you disagreed with?
Yeah,
so shit like it's just an opinion.
So stance,
but like that's what me and your job,
the reason people follow us is to hear our opinions on things.
You know what I mean?
If we didn't want people to know that stuff,
neither of us would be on Twitter.
Neither of us would be fucking comedians.
Right.
You just happen to disagree with this one.
Well,
it's not just that I disagree with it.
It's at every single comedian that I've talked to about it disagrees with it.
She disagrees with it vehemently and believes that you
popular stance,
not just that you didn't take the popular stance,
you didn't take the stance that comes from the people that do the job and know
how difficult it is to do an ad lib scenario like what Tosh was doing and to
have someone on ironically shout out,
actually rape has never funny while he was talking about how rape isn't fun.
And again,
like now we're getting back to like defending the heckler.
Like I'm not defending the fucking heckler are,
I don't know.
This is by saying that what he's done is bad.
You're saying that what she did was not as bad and what he did only existed
because she did something right.
Holla.
But again,
like when the dude threatened me like that then become a big thing.
What do threaten Twitter?
Who threatened?
No,
no,
the war guy.
Do you know what I mean with that hair?
You know what I mean?
Like,
like he had to become a life threat.
That guy,
the guy who said he was,
I was,
if I kept talking to,
he's going to be the shit at cap city.
Oh.
Where it's like know that's an artist like you fuck around and Austin son like
that sucks.
You know what I mean?
Like to deal with like a worse version of a heckler.
Yeah.
That's worse than what you did and still not so still stupid dance.
But I'm,
we're going to disagree on this forever.
Listen man.
I think ultimately though we agree that it's,
it's about being a good person and you what you think is that talking and joking
around about violent acts is not a part of being a good person.
I and I,
I seen out the word totally fine.
Your point culture,
not the rape scenarios or whatever about bikes specifically,
like the punchline is the person who's right.
I think that's fucking lazy,
lazy comedy,
just like racial stereotypes,
I think,
or it's fucking lazy.
I think people can be funnier and more creative than that.
Yes,
I totally see that.
I don't delete think it's lazy.
I think it was the perfect thing to say and that scenario,
if,
if it's been reported exactly the way I described,
how does it,
that's really what happened.
Yeah.
I don't,
you know what?
He's just joking.
He's just everyone pretending that this is some sort of a real national debate.
Look,
one in six commonality is we should be nice to each other for sure,
but it's also reality is you should yell out stupid shit at a comedy club and
here's another reality.
There's a lot of dumb people that don't know they're dumb and that's part of
being dumb and you know,
and you,
you have this fucking wild ass stupid opinion.
You'd think the whole world should here.
Right?
And you want to stand up and yell at,
I mean I had it a couple of weeks ago in Calgary,
some dumb guy just stood up and started yelling something in the middle of show
and we have to wait while he gets kicked out.
And he was like yelling and laughing.
Then he got kicked out and everyone is booing at them.
It's a part of life.
You're going to have to deal with that sort of a thing.
But when you're a stand up comic,
you know what the fuck he's doing.
You know what he's going through.
He's not supporting rape and he's certainly not supporting rape culture,
which supports rape.
He's not,
he's telling a joke.
He's doing a joke just as if he would be doing a joke about murdering somebody.
I just think you've got to pick a team so on.
We're on teams.
Stand up.
All right.
Damn it.
Listen this Friday we've got a killer show here at the Ice House,
Ladies and gentlemen.
It's getting deeper as we speak.
Greg Fitz Simmons,
Joey Diaz,
Dom,
I rera,
Brian,
red band and me that's of now and Brian and I are going to talk off the show and
maybe add some more mobile,
more.
Have a secret.
Let's just say somebody that will be really good if he,
if he tells me yes,
he's going to tell me yes or no,
and it's a Jeffrey Ross.
Me.
Oh,
Jeff Ross would be awesome as the show starts tonight.
Don't sit in the front row.
It's Jeff Ross.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
just a new roasting show on comedy central.
All right.
Thank you Jamie.
And listen man,
you know I love you even
though we disagree.
I think you're a great guy and I just want,
you know,
we,
we can all have our differences of opinions on things and you know,
and I know I got a little aggressive with you,
hearing held you to the fire,
but in no way is it that I disrespect you or don't like you or like hanging out
with you.
We're talking to you or it's just,
it's a tricky situation and it's very passionate one to me.
And of course rape is terrible.
Folks with a bat.
Conti behaviors.
Terrible
with Lizz.
Winstead did when I was an open miker was fucking terrible.
Brian coin.
I got your back son 20 plus years later.
Holla at your boy if he's still alive.
Wow.
That got dark folks tomorrow night or tomorrow day.
Andrew motherfucking dice clay Thursday.
Everlast hell yeah.
Shit's getting crazy here at the ice house.
Uh,
and uh,
of course Friday night we will have the ice house chronicles which just listen
to the lineup we just said Greg Fitzsimmons,
dom I rera Joey Diaz,
Brian red ban on the hinge.
Tony Hinchcliffe,
who's Hilarious,
hilarious young comic who does a lot of the hosting that we have at the
icehouse.
He's and he's fucking great man.
I watched them again last week.
He's great at work in the crowd.
He's great at ad libbing.
Thanks to Anna Dotcom for supporting our show.
Thanks to a alien ware for hooking us up with some sweet products.
This laptop is the shit.
And if you're into gaming,
it's perfect for you.
Follow Alienware MMA on Twitter.
Follow red ban on Twitter.
Follow Jamie Kilstein on Twitter and be nice.
Come on folks.
We can agree to disagree.
Benign,
much raping my timeline.
I'm sure his time where is more.
There is more than one in six rape threats in my timeline.
Come on folks.
You don't have to rape.
Jamie's the time.
79 mentioned garden,
but seven times,
seven times you fucked seven times.
You pull
over and over again.
Look,
folks,
love and happiness is the only key to life if you want to,
if you want to be a happy person,
you got to do a couple of times.
One,
you got to get your own shit together so that nice people would want to be
around you,
okay?
Because if you don't have your own shit together,
you're not going to attract nice people.
It's just a fact.
Nice people don't want to deal with your bullshit.
And if they do deal with your bullshit,
you're making them a victim and they're enabling you,
so get it together.
You dirty fucking freaks.
Thanks to ana.com go buy yourself some Alpha brain to get clear thoughts like
these.
This podcast is also brought to you by our silence sponsor,
marijuana,
which is illegal federally,
but yet awesome.
And a available here in California through select loopholes.
Go to [inaudible] dot com if you want to get some non marijuana hemp force
protein,
it's hemp is not marijuana,
even though it's illegal,
but you can buy it and bring it in here.
It doesn't make any fucking sense.
We're living in a fucking police states run by corporations.
Jamie Kilstein,
break it down for folks.
This is the last words.
Say it,
Jamie corporations and rape her bad.
All that Shit's bad.
Folks.
We love you and uh,
we'll see you soon.
Thank you for all the positive support.
Thank you.
Everybody came out to the show in Denver.
It was fucking beyond fantastic.
We are on a crazy role.
We're all in this thing together.
Fucking phrase girl raped me.
He threw me on the ground and then she used covered in blood.
He's gonna.
Rape is rape culture.
Shut it off quickly.
You supporting girls raping you.
All right.
We love you guys and we will see you tomorrow.
Thank you everybody.